in accordance with household 67 and the
governor's emergency order 12 pursuant
to executive order 2020-04 this public
body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is an executive session on
senate bill 58 and senate bill 104 is
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today
an executive session may be held
on any bill
referred to this committee please note
that there's no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
subcommittee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoo
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporaneously
listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general work website
this meeting does comply with house
rules and rsa 91a if anyone has a
problem accessing they should call 271
in the ledge.state.nh.us.com the public
is unable to attend the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
please note that all votes taken will be
done by a roll call
and we will start the meeting by taking
a roll call attendance of the
subcommittee representative allegro here
representative
sentence
here in uh winston alone
and i for the first time in my life i
prom did i say that correctly i don't
well i turned my my my camera on i am
present in my home office and i am alone
i am present at my home and mr chair uh
just a slight correction
this is technically a
subcommittee executive session it can't
be an executive session until we have
the whole community you are correct
we are just the subcommittee is
she's going to vote on the
uh on our
work on the two bills
he did announce it was a subcommittee
meeting
yes but he also stated during his spiel
that it was an executive session so yeah
i guess i guess technically we're just
voting voting a recommendation on the on
the amendments and that's technically
not all right thank you yes and myself
i'm chairman of pearson
in the room all right so we'll start
with 58.
this is
substantially lengthy but it was due to
the repetition of
the various
boards and the consistency that was
being
desired across the plc
took care of some of the concern or
about some of the concerns all of the
concerns that the subcommittee had
brought
especially when it came to the
signature part and
the
references that
representative golding made
concerning the
consultation with the appropriate boards
or
hiring of investigators and legal
services and that sort of thing so
i hope
that you all had a
chance to peruse it i've discussed this
mr chair
we went through that yes representative
yes um i do have a question which
i'm sorry i did not bring up before but
um
i noticed on page three
under the
acupuncture professionals
is this
page three the original bill or page
three well yeah i think it's page three
of of the amendment also since it
basically
likes the entire
reiterates the entire bill technically
and i'm not i mean it's the same in both
[Music]
and it talks about
uh it's line 14 in the original bill
and it's also it's a strikeout it's also
struck out in the amendment
and it talks about maintaining a roster
of all acupuncture's licensed
acupuncturists
licensed under this chapter
um and i don't know if ms courtney is
here
uh i'm curious does that mean there is
no longer going to be
a list thing available to the public
of
who they can consider to be
registered
miss courtney is here and i just
promoted her over so um
she can speak if she unmutes herself
thank you
thank you mr chair members of the
subcommittee lindsay courtney executive
director
um and thank you representative stuart
for that question
um
no so we maintain a licensee database
it's our called arm uh licensing up
through our online portal that anybody
can go in and look up a licensed
um individual their status their license
history and whether or not there's any
disciplinary action
um the roster that we've actually
proposed to eliminate throughout this
bill from
certain practice acts that contain that
language
is a separate document that some boards
have maintained
and charged people a fee
for um we we don't think that it made
sense to be doing that
particularly because it's available for
free on the web
um and it just requires us to maintain a
separate list and
um is is more burdensome to administer
so we would still be maintaining our
licensee look up through the online
portal just not maintaining a separate
public list that's available for
purchase
yes uh i assume and hope that uh there
would be
some kind of
reference if someone went to
the acupuncturist's
individual location referring people
that are
interested to look at your
uh
compilation list i'll call it
yes so if you go to our new website um
there's a whole uh there's a tab a new
section that says licensee look up for
individuals to go and look up a license
and i believe there's a separate tab on
each board webpage as well that is a
question that we get frequently
um so we're trying to make it
easier for people to access
it makes sense like i said i just i
would think if somebody was looking for
a specific profession
they would go to that board so i just
want to be sure that there's something
that's going to direct them to where
they can find that
so just a reminder for those out in
cyberspace the purpose of this senate
bill is to
provide consistency and some
standardization across
rewards when it comes to the
operations of oplc specifically
and the boards have retained their
ability to function in
certain aspects of thomas so
if there's if there's no other concerns
on
the work that was done in the amendment
the final amendment that was drafted
i certainly don't have i think that
this was this was laid out as uh
and our concerns were well addressed in
the one spot where we weren't quite
consistent across the plc took care of
so
representative schmidt
anything
no i'm good
excellent so if we're all good then
we'll just take a subcommittee
recommendation vote on uh
what would be now known as the pearson
and i'll uh
i'll call the role for for the
representatives
yes
and representative schuett
all right next is according to one of
the clocks in the room
they're not the same well we have
technically three minutes or so before
we move on to 104 so just take a moment
to peruse
right
[Music]
absolutely
i'm i'm going over my notes on 104 and
there
by comparison to 58 virtually none um
just
what
the hang up was
very quiet
sure
i'm sorry did you say what could i just
review what the amendment included
yeah what what was changed
sure entire amendment to the pearson
amendment
um
we the the first thing we did was in in
part one which um outlines the
the uh unclassified positions that have
been
voted on by the joint committee on
employee classification it already had
some votes from last year but the the
joint committee just met a couple of
weeks ago and approved some new
unclassified salary changes and so those
were incorporated into the amendment to
to bring everything
all of their work up to date in the
statutes
and then um
in in part two of the amendment
uh we we took the
carson amendment that had been a
separate amendment that dealt with
reverse auctions and incorporated that
into part two
and then
we added a new part three
using the mcguire amendment which
had the
organization of the department of
administrative services changes that
commissioner arlinghaus
talked to you about so so it was a
relatively simple amendment we just
lifted those separate amendments and put
them all into one that's why i don't
have a lot of notes on it right
nomination of the various parts into one
document
awesome
[Music]
rp 945 i'll open the subcommittee
hearing on senate bill 104.
the
this is recorded it doesn't stop
recording as it was previously stated
enough to repeat it the carson amendment
the mcguire amendment and the
new classifications that jcec had
just worked out
have now been
incorporated into one document
did not
have any issues originally with changing
anything which was fantastic it was just
necessary to
merge all these together to form one
mr chairman just so you know there is
some um
gary lunetta is in the attendees and has
i don't know what his interest is but uh
oh he put his hand down
maybe
this is a as this is the
subcommittee name that's gone beyond its
public hearing it will have to be
extremely relevant
okay he put his hand back up again so
here he is um if he
wants to unmute himself he'll be able to
speak
go ahead sir
good morning i just wanted to introduce
that i'm on the line i have tom carr
with me from das so if there are any
questions we're happy to uh
to
could you say to us again from deep
you said dhs or d-e-s
administrative services administrative
we
uh testified at the original hearing and
answered lengthy questions in my notes
yep i know we had concerns
we asked questions in reference to what
jcec was doing
um
and that's the timing of that so
and i'm glad that we're able to
incorporate their recent
work into this so we don't have to wait
a year
right
we've probably already waited a year
actually
after that
yeah well like i said there's no sense
in putting it off if we can get it done
i'm good with this the melding of this
together
while we're waiting mr chairman um
just to state for the record
of this meeting uh
as um one of the members of the
jcec and as a former chair
uh
i've experienced in this matter and
and pam is our staffer on jcec so she is
a a long time staffer of the jcec so she
also would have a lot of
information if there were any issues
that needed to be addressed
thank you
all right an advantage
with that
certainly i have a question on the
amendment
which one
on um
at the very end on the effective dates
and i could have very well gotten this
wrong
my scribbled notes during our meeting
we had
part three for administrative services
being added in the effect dates at the
end and i see that but i had also
after
uh on the effective dates and i don't
know maybe it was decided that
that wasn't needed but i don't see part
four
specifically listed in the effective
dates of the amendment
so maybe ms smarling could tell us
if i got that wrong or what
i'm not aware of a part four we we had
originally the bill had only two parts
and then we added a a third
but um
i don't know what
part four would be referring to i'm not
sure what i was referring to okay
like i said i put part three after the
perhaps
perhaps you're just preparing yourself
to write part four if there were one
maybe
i'm not aware of a discussion of a part
yeah this is uh this has
does what it needs because this is not a
full right this is uh it's almost a full
rewrite
but not not quite
not entirely right right so the
effective dates for each section do
exist
one of which is specific to july 1 which
is if the score opens
and then the other part two was sixty
with sixty days
yep six part one is sixty days part two
is
so we do have effective dates for
this
now where we are it's going to push it
into the next july 1.
do we have
effective date for part one
yes
original bill
will be located online 21
part one of this actually take effect 60
days after it's passed okay
thank you
so so part one and two are going to push
past into the end of july depending on
how fast this makes it through i mean if
it gets the recession that's the first
week of june which will be august
actually
and then part of the third part
will go in effect july 1st of this year
according to the amendment correct okay
all right i think i'm good wonderful
we're good here at uh mission control so
if there's anybody else
if there's no other questions we'll just
i don't see any hands raised
all right marvelous well then let's uh
we'll just do roll call on the
amendment
2021-15148
and i will
representative
stockton
yes
representative schmidt yes
and representative schuett
yeah
and the chair of boots yes as well
wonderful great job everybody getting
through those especially 58 which was
substantially
not very often you you reference
you know a line on page 52 with a
in a fill
fantastic and hopefully we'll be able to
process things today and
committed
so with that i'll close the subcommittee
hearing on
104 and we will be returned until i
believe 10 30
for the full committee
you mr chairman well done thank you guys
okay i'll post the notice and um i can
mute the room from up here just
as always remember to unmute when you're
ready to go again i think i wasn't
unmuted i said good job mr chair
okay you may start whenever
then just call just call in and i'll uh
talk about some other things before you
a way for the uh state parties and
statewide candidates to get lists
without a few voters
if that does not contain
the trust that it's mailed to then
modifying that
next
i'd appreciate it
you've been promoted
is
all right good morning everyone welcome
to edna
it's 10 30
and i'm
opening the executive session
start with reading our script
as chair of the house dna committee i
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the public 19 pandemic and in accordance
with house rule 67 the governor's church
emergency quarter number 12 first went
to executive order
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a this is an
executive session
on bills referred to the committee and
scheduled in the house calendar for
today
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee please
note there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if invited participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available for the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271 3600 or email
hcs
ledge.state.mh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll paul
we'll start the meeting by taking roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state that
there is anyone in the room with you
during the meeting which is required
representative allegro
present
in the room
representative bailey present committee
room representative fellows
who is this please
representative
i'm sorry i didn't know i was called uh
i'm present
on my patio at home
uh my wife is also working out here
okay
home and then my wife is in the other
room
representative grota
home office alone
representative judy
welcome back
i don't see him yet but i'll let you
know when he shows up hey thank you
representative lonzara
good morning i'm home in nashua uh some
family throughout the house
representative
president in the committee room
president of mcguire
representative o'brien saw a little
are you there
welcome back welcome back uh
representative peterson representative
pearson is in the committee room
representative ryan
representative roy is home alone
representative
i'm here
alone
i am president of my home office in
dover i am alone
representative
i am present at my home in pembroke
alone
representative schultz
i am
in my home in concord my husband gene
taylor will be in and out of the room
works in the committee room
representative
here at home alone in the room
and we will try again for representative
judy
okay please let me know if anybody
notices him and representative um
um
i
okay uh representative judy and o'brien
did not answer the role at this time
the rest are here
okay
all right
we don't have the final amendment for
senate bill 133
so we would take care of our other two
[Music]
representative pearson here i am going
to move
autopass
amendment
and the number is the amendment number
thank you the subcommittee
actually worked
two sessions here to
outline
[Music]
concerns that were brought up during
both the public hearing and in
subcommittee
sessions the
this basically boils down to is oplc is
and as it should be trying to remind its
operations
so you can do that there were some
inconsistencies across the
54 wars and
this is not um
this is not to
advance the force itself it is just to
work
the particulars of the commonalities
across the operations of oplc
so the
one of the things that
the subcommittee did work on that was a
change to the original bill was we
removed the requirement for physical
signatures
uh in this age of
websites electronic meetings and such it
seemed to be very burdensome to
to require those to be physically done
so
amongst amongst a couple other changes
that was that was one that was kind of a
big one the other thing of course if you
recall from the hearing is we were all
kind of taken aback a little bit of the
fact that oplc issued 25 000 temporary
licenses last year which is uh
which was a staggering number pretty
much all of us so
um
but yeah the subcommittee voted 5-0 to
approve the
final amendment to the bill which
rewrites the entire
after the basically the inaction
sentence at the beginning so it is a
okay representation
[Music]
thank you i think representative pearson
covered um
the territory the subcommittee
finally did agree on just
moments ago
all right excellent
are there any other comments questions
uh madam chair if i may
uh representative o'brien i apologize
for being late but i'm in attendance uh
i'm at home alone in nashua
thank you representative o'brien glad to
hear from you do you have any questions
anyone else
i'm sorry could you kindly repeat the
amendment number i was distracted when
it was read and i and i just want to
make it for my notes thank you
53 pages of
fine points
yes
all right seeing no questions or
comments
the motion is to approve amendment
153h to senate bill 58
and the clerk can hold the rule
representative roy
yes
the clerk wrote yes representative
pearson yes representative yakovich
yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes
representative monzara
yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes
representative
representative judy
not yet
[Music]
representative schmidt yes
representative schultz
yes
representative fellows
representative pintel
yes representative grota
yes
representative o'brien
the chair
yes 18 to nothing with adoption of the
amendment
[Music]
is there a second
auto second
well
since it's a full rewrite we've covered
that uh we covered that under the
hello
it seems the longer the bill the shorter
speech
[Laughter]
so in that case if there's no other
comments i'd like to thank the
subcommittee
for going through this
and getting
a lot of cleanup done
and
it's
not something that you'll get a lot of
praise from from your constituents
but it is necessary
so the clerk the motion is ought to pass
with amendment
on senate bill 58.
representative roy
yes
yes representative pearson yes
representative
yes
representative allegro yes represent
bailey yes represent manzara
yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes
representative short
as a member of the subcommittee thank
you madam chair and i vote yes
uh representative judy have you shown
yet
not yet representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
representative uh pimentel
yes
representative
with appreciation yes
representative bryant
yes
schuett schultz and schmidt very hard to
abbreviate
many times
nobody tell us a part either
no objection to consent correct i had it
okay
sure would like to
move
senate bill 104 with uh and we'll
discuss the amendment
2021-1514h
i do thank you madam chair the
the amendment it is in a couple of parts
it's in particular three parts so the
first part covers the
classification of certain jobs within
the state and
puts them into their salary
classification
the
committee jcec which is the
committee that looks at salaries within
the state actually had just met prior to
our work so we were able to
incorporate the new work of that
committee into this
amendment which is uh
quite timely considering that usually
they get stuck waiting a year for things
to catch up so we were we were happy to
come
oblige their
the timing of that and bring that into
part one with the classifications the
second part
is
just really
has to do with the um reverse the
concept of reverse auctions
it is it is not what you see on
television as far as like selling your
home and that kind of thing this is more
of a procurement thing where
it gives the the state a little bit of a
ability to to get work done at all
at a lower cost the third part
involved
the department of administrative
services
some title changes of some jobs that i
guess we just we don't call them what we
used to so there was that and then
the other thing was just the way
um the commissioners have the ability to
appoint their deputies
so and that's pretty much uh
the gist of that there was a little bit
of language cleanup again like i said
with
you know
things aren't
called what they used to be called but
that's pretty much straightforward with
with 104. and the subcommittee was
the blending of of the three original
amendments into the final this final
amendment okay
thank you sorry
as before i think the subcommittee chair
i'd like to comment that one of the
things
part three does
is that it
moves a number of the top level
employees and administrative services
from classified to unclassified
positions
which is more appropriate for that level
other questions comments concerns
madam chair i made uh one one
final comment on this if i may
please president
thank you so
for the committee's edification uh one
of the things that is has
been tangentially discussed this morning
or mentioned uh is that
the as the executive department the
branch of uh
of the government
modifies work procedures and so forth
and
ultimately those changes need to be
reflected in the job title that was
referenced earlier but
in in accordance with uh
statutory requirement uh we have to
change uh the statute to reflect
not merely the job title but also the
job description uh which is um
a part of the whole process so
that's one of the functions of jcec
which has not yet been described to the
committee so just mentioning that so
it's job title and description uh have
to be changed to modify and modify to
reflect what the employee's actually
doing
uh in many cases
uh so that we are in sync
and that's
uh something we should keep in mind as
we adopt these measures
that we are making our statutes reflect
reality thank you
okay
uh in that case the motion is to adopt
amendment one five one four h to senate
representative roy yes
reports yes representative pearson yes
representative
yes
yes representative allegro yes represent
bailey yes representative representative
lanzaro
yes represent santo mustafa yes
representative goalie
yes
representative short
representative
judy are you here
he is
not uh representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
representative fellows
yes
representative pimentel
yes representative grota
yes
representative o'brien
the chair yes
it is 18 to nothing for adoption of the
amendment
excellent representative pearson
thank you madam chair i'd like to move
second
[Music]
uh again similar to the other bill where
it's a substantial
rewrite um
i think we pretty much covered the gist
i don't see any
another uh
fine fine job of cleaning up our statues
and clarifying what we're doing with the
city police
and the motion is ought to pass with
amendment and the clerk
representative right
yes
yes representative pearson yes
representative
yes
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzara
yes
representative goalie
representative
yes
no representative judy
representative schmidt yes
representative schultz
yes
representative fellows
representative
yes
representative grota
representative o'brien
yes
and the chair yes 18 to nothing but
adoption
what to pass
out
and we do not have the final amendment
for senator 133 so we can't take that
out
so
uh
see
the only other thing we could probably
do if
representative roy is ready to do so
is to go through the sections of senate
bill 155
other than the non-german amendment
that's preparing this afternoon
and
brief the committee on those and take a
vote on them representative roy you
i could do that if you just give me a
minute to pull up the documents
since we're here we might as well go
through the sections
thank you for this madam chair because
uh this is a you know another lengthy
bill omnis and uh doing it now makes
eminent sense
utilizing our time effectively i
appreciate that
and also while representative roy is is
getting his uh
his paperwork together
i i did bring
copies of the
sort of the draft the subcommittee draft
for 133 down to the committee room and
emailed it to all the members this
morning
so you
if you wanted to do something similar
for 133 that's an option you have a
document you could work from
and and also um dr warner's suggestion
for amendments to part 12. i don't know
if you wanted to address that but that
is has been sent around and and copies
um are in the committee room as well
we've already voted on every section of
133 we're just waiting for the final
amendment i would rather do 155 first
and then reconsider part 12 if we wish
to afterwards okay i'm just just
throwing it out there right
thank you i appreciate that
pam do you have um the collection of
changes to 155 handy that we're going to
be
um
and not not immediately handy i was
okay i do have it in front of me now
is that
1443 h is down in the committee room
that's the amount right that's the
non-germain amendment
[Music]
i don't think we have an amendment for
155 yet but are you looking for general
i mean i think we could provide general
information as to what
we did with house bill 155 and
subcommittee is that what you're looking
for madam chair are you looking for
exact wording
uh for the most part
if you have exact wording i would very
much like to use it if you do not have
an exact wording
consider the intent
i i believe miss smarling has the exact
wording we submitted to her on each
section of the bill
yes
okay so go through
um
section one temporary health department
what did
representative roy what did you do with
so we decided that um we wanted to have
a definition of what temporary health
partner means
um since there was not one in the bill
so we came up with a definition and mr
marlin could perhaps read that for us
sure it's it's relatively brief so
hopefully it will be relatively painless
we say for the purposes of this section
temporary health partner means a health
partner who has been hired under the
processes
authorized according to federal and
state waivers
thank you and that was um in response to
um representative goalie had brought up
the point that you know and we all
agreed that we did not want to create a
permanent subclass
of lna
that would just stay there at a lower
pay rate in replace of regular lnas
so what we wanted was um something that
provided a pathway for people only who
were hired during this emergency and
received waivers once the emergency is
over and the waivers are done so this
program ends with it
and so do the opportunities for them to
use
the hours they've collected towards
getting their lna
we discussed with the
nursing people about bringing back new
legislation that
would perhaps provide a
alternate pathway for people to get
their lna but that would be something
addressed later on but for the purposes
of this section this is only for people
hired
using waivers from the
emergency orders and when the emergency
and i hope representative goalie that
addressed the concerns you have
yes it does thank you representative
representative
yes i think that this is fantastic and i
think
just uh
put a pen in this for the futures i
think we should look at this as
something to go beyond
um to to extend beyond that time frame
i think this is a great pathway that
can create a good career for folks
representative
yes
child yes
the general question is there's still
such a thing as an lpn
yes that's a more skilled position okay
but that exists this hasn't been
mentioned
yeah that's one above lna i believe
it's also referenced on line 11.
thank you representative pearson
my question is
i understand the change we just talked
about
is that section going to have an expired
date
sometime in the future
so
if the emergency orders expire the the
pool of
eligible people won't expand but
shouldn't we have some kind of expiry
date
you know several years out from now
the waiver has a
an expiration date at the end of the
emergency
so you can't hire new people from that
um there's another thing i should have
mentioned i i apologize we the other
change that the subcommittee agreed to
was to
rather than um amend rsa 326b as as is
done in the bill as um
adopted by the senate we've made it
session law so it still remains in
effect until repealed but it's it's not
a sort of permanent looking position uh
section in the the nurse practice act
so
and and of course what representative
mcguire just said is is correct when the
waivers disappear the the
or at the very least i can't hire
anybody new
and we have in senate bill 133 a way for
them to apply for an lna license
but we would after the end of the
emergency you can't hire any more
temporary health classes
right and since we put it in session law
it will not be there cluttering up
permanently the uh the section related
to
l
thank you ma'am chair i i would like to
say that uh these people are already
helping us out right now and doing an
extraordinarily important
job of making it possible for the
trained nursing staff
to do
the things that they alone are trained
for
but the
functions that the uh that these
temporary health workers helpers are
doing are
absolutely crucial
uh
for
uh these frail patients who are in many
cases are unable to feed themselves or
toilet themselves and so forth
these are
and without these functions performed
they cannot
they can't survive here in these nursing
homes so these these workers are vital
and they have responded to this pandemic
stepped forward
and this it would be a way for them to
work their way up to lna uh as the
situation comes along and and
in advance that grade when this position
goes away at the end of the pandemic
so
very important what they're doing
indeed any any other comments questions
um can you read the title off for me i
don't have the document in front of me
authorizes emergency licensing of
and i'd be happy to step in if you
would like
if you would please what we should
thank you
sure if um if looking at the bill is
amended by the senate on page three
um
lines 16 through 22
talk about
current and former military service
members
and how they
could be i could apply for a nursing
assistant license as well as emts and
since those
both those categories of people were
addressed in house bill 567 the
subcommittee
removed both of those paragraphs from
the bill
and and i just noticed as i was looking
at this that that there is there are two
paragraph fours so we there's a
paragraph four on on line nine and a
paragraph four on line 16 right below it
so
um make sure that we
don't delete both of them
but
that's that's the substance of of the
subcommittee's work to remove those two
paragraphs
and if you recall uh representative
madam chair that that was at your behalf
that we um we that already existed in in
another statute
and pam will that require renumbering of
the of the page if we do that
yes
but
it'll require
changing roman 6 to romans 5.
right
won't affect the other paragraph four
okay
right we'll just make sure that we get
by the executive session we noticed
that there were two section fours
anything
questions comments or concerns on this
change
that so section three is about
pharmacists
um i believe i believe we thought that
was a good idea miss marlin did we make
any changes to that section
i no we did not no so we we thought that
that was a good idea
um to allow the pharmacist's assistance
the ability to do that
there's one
concern that was brought up by
the chair of hhs that they had
the pharmacist vaccines
in a different field
which i thought i had sent to
smarling but it did not include the
testing
so let's
connect
look at that and take out the
vaccinations because
as i understand it the vaccine section
was
in the other bills number i forget was
more thorough and better integrated
yeah i thought that was in section four
i thought we were going to look at that
to make sure that it was covered before
we agreed to delete it to make sure that
the language was adequate
side by side did we get that smart
oh i did not
know about that request
the testing is new in this bill and
should stay but the vaccination part we
want to make sure doesn't
contradict what
another committee's done on a different
field
right and so that's section five
correct uh section three
section
the second uh
i had thought that that's the one that
you wanted to remove section five
relative to the pharmacy tech
administration of vaccines
sections 3 and 4
are
about testing
and i don't that's duplicated anywhere
section 5. is
um
again
we don't object to the idea we just
don't want to duplicate effort
right and that
that was the section i had thought we
were talking about removing
yes
all right
i have the number of the other bill by
the chance anyone
uh 572
okay
then on page five we go on to the next
section which is out of state pharmacy
as temporary limited licensed mail-order
facilities
and that that one we also agreed was a
good idea um
and we did not if i recall make any
changes to that
that's correct
um
this would uh allow the out-of-state
pharmacies to fulfill these
prescriptions
yeah these are um
it's a very limited number of things
it's uh prescriptions for people who are
it's not a general thing
right and it saves people from having to
drive a long way to get their
prescriptions
um that would not otherwise be available
here in new hampshire and i believe
representative luck has spoke to that
personally
and the next is
protection of pre-existing
non-conforming use status for summer
games this one we did make some
significant changes to um
with regard i believe to a sunset and to
ensure that
summer camps that were grandfathered did
not lose that status in the future mr
smalling do you have the language we
came up with
yeah um representative lekkis worked on
this section i'm sure he'll he he can
talk about it as well but basically he
he extended it to apply to summer camps
that were under operation in 2021
either it's currently
for the camps
that were closed rather in 2020 and
that's extended to include
um 2021.
or 2020.
um and and we there was a lot of
discussion about whether the sunset
should apply
and it was determined that it should not
that it should remain in the statute
just so summer camps that might have
sort of lapsed during this covid period
would be able to point to a
a clear law say in 2025 to show why they
had not been in operation
yeah that's that's right thank you for
refreshing my memory we decided that if
somewhere down the road um the status of
a summer camp were challenged because of
their inability to operate these during
these two years
they would be able to point to the
specific statute that authorized them to
yes um
we added 2021 in addition because this
bill doesn't just
it can't be closed
but if they're operating at reduced
capacity because there might be some
requirements around that
and the concern is that we hope it's not
going to happen but it's possible
some camps could experience that this
any other comments or questions on
but we're happy with that one
uh
next section is on continuing
construction
can you read that again i didn't hear
what you said is on what
continuing construction during covet 19.
um okay so i don't know that we made any
changes to this one this morning did we
represent
karen i believe we removed the whole
section because uh the testimony we got
indicated it was no longer an issue
that's right it was um
that's correct we we struck the entire
section because
um it really wasn't if
it didn't matter anymore at this point
because everything was opened back up
when construction had started again
okay
okay section nine outdoor dinings
[Music]
uh this one uh representative grotto put
a lot of work into for us um checking on
it and uh i let her go ahead and tell us
what she came up with
sure there were two uh concerns one
had to do with um des and sept and those
uh phys those um businesses on subject
systems
so it was uh the amendment
excuse me um addresses that concern by
saying that
those um establishments on septic
systems if they have um if they want to
have a capacity
larger than what they have um
that what they're normally allotted they
have to have review of their success
their system with des
per ds rsas and there is a let a
sentence in there that reinforces local
control in that all outdoor dining those
facilities that are not that are on
municipal systems
have to um follow the municipal
guidelines and the the you know the
municipality makes the decisions on that
so it gives local control to those
facilities
if you'd like me to read the exact
sentences i can do that if you prefer
okay no i think that makes sense
uh
i did i did hear from um yesterday from
someone from the liquor commission
um and they were requesting something
about
having the statute put in the
having any change to the statute put in
with their their existing statutes and
he's supposed to be sending me
um
specific language as to where they would
like that place
so once i get that um we'll represent
that to the committee just to
button that down i think that if if i
remember the discussion correctly it's
178.24
which talks about
authorization for other areas
um
they they include that already has the
requirements for local local control and
local approval
and uh so anything that we you think you
need to add
in
would would go
much more conveniently and that's in
that section of statute rather than
creating
okay and that's the that's the last of
it other than the prospective repeals
and the effective dates
representative fellows has her
yes i just had
a question about the end date for the
outdoor dining did you change that or is
it still through
i do not believe we changed it did we
represent um smiling
no no
thanks for the promotion though
um
we did not change that uh representative
fellows
um and in in closing i would just like
to say a pox on the senate for all these
uh omnibus bills
[Music]
thank you madam chair and i just
i thought this goes to representative
roy i thought we had discussed changing
it uh to 2022
knowing that they would give two full
years and if it needed to be extended
out we could do that further on but uh
going to the end of 2023 seemed kind of
lengthy
i'm not sure if he recalls that
discussion or not but i thought we were
going to change the end date
i recall that true
i i do recall that um i don't know that
um
perhaps representative grota didn't put
that in her
representative lekkis has a comment on
that specific issue
representative
thank you
the businesses to if they haven't
already expanded the outdoor dining
there's a certain amount of investment
in that to give them
you know
i don't know that we took a formal vote
in the committee but
yeah if i recall the the reasons i'm
trying to remember who who testified um
but they they indicated that it would
give the businesses some some sense of
security as far as planning and
investment to at least know that they
had um another year without having to
they'd be able to make investments and
such
that's great there was we had um let me
just think about who that would be
it was the municipal association perhaps
the municipal association i think was
margaret burns actually and i she um
mentioned that and this is you know i
know this is true in our own town
these businesses that are either having
outdoor dining are making significant
investments with
making things look less
more aesthetically pleasing
and that
in order to um
to do this
they are they're wanting to make sure
that
should things continue they can can they
can continue to have these outdoor
dining through
that's how i think about this isn't that
the date that that we discussed madam
chair for me yes representative goalie
i i
if i remember correctly the discussion
was around the date and we the
discussion was that
they have all of this year
and all of 2022 which is two full
summers um
to get through this
and if need be
in 2022 if we need to go a third year
it could be extended at that time but i
thought the discussion was 2022 would
suffice and if needed we could extend it
out but this gives cities and towns two
full summers
and into the fall
of next year
to get through this and
gives us time to reassess if we go to
2022 as to whether or not it's needed in
2023. i think that's what the discussion
was that i recall
okay
your discussion is correct but i thought
we had another meeting that you weren't
you had a comment yeah i just uh said it
was interesting that the support for uh
keeping it extended inside of the call i
think you're right it was from uh
somebody from the municipal association
which was
a little surprising but
i just i i seem to recall we had a
second meeting on this subcommittee and
i'm not sure if representative goalie
was
present when we heard that testimony
i was not there
okay
that case well i think
if there's still a question about it
uh the lat
from listening to people the
um
the summation that i hear is that
there's going to be no change
to
and therefore
i'd like i'd like to hear it
representative roy do you have a do you
plan to bring that up again
um based on the the testimony we heard
from the municipal association i did not
intend to to change it um
the only the only contrary um with
respect was representative goalie and i
understand where he's coming from
but based on the request of the people
actually out there dealing with it we
but i'm pretty um switzerland either way
represent fellows
thank you ma'am chair i'm i'd just like
to say that that i'm
fine with keeping the date the way it is
now that i've heard the explanation i
listened to some of the subcommittee
meetings but i didn't listen to the
whole thing
so i think that i listened to the first
discussion when it sounded like we were
going to change the date and i didn't
hear the second part so i'm i'm fine
with it
i also think that if i may that's it i
mean it doesn't mean i'm sorry this is i
should i i i meant to raise my hand
go ahead representative
okay thank you i also um
this is this this is a sunset sunset
date but it doesn't mean that it can't
happen before that and that's why
putting it under local control and
leaving it under local control is
important because for example in the
city of portsmouth if this gets to be
too cumbersome
and it's not needed then the city
themselves can the city council can
decide on their own as long as they're
following the rules
or if
if nashville for example decides that
they really need those two lanes of main
street again
right
downstream they they can
do that on a
i think i heard you call my name you
broke up
i think it's important we all know uh
how much restaurants uh have suffered as
a result of the pandemic uh and this is
an attempt to uh to do as much as we can
always
leaving the local control as a as an
important aspect
but to do as much as we can to try to do
the right thing here and now that we
have the full committee assembled and
representative judy has joined us as
some of you may have noticed uh i think
that to try to get the combined wisdom
of the committee a number of the members
are from the smaller towns
where it's a
different situation to some degree than
it is uh in the larger cities such as we
have um so i think we ought to try and
resolve this to the to the greatest
extent we can in favor of the
[Music]
so
the temporary health partners will be
amended for clarity and clean session
law
uh
emergency licensing you're you're
appealing
oh sorry
not making a change to that
uh section three focus on on testing
not vaccines
on other state investigation
other state pharmacies left that alone
summer camps extend through this summer
delete the section on construction
changes
and
uh modification to clarify the outdoor
banking situation
that sums it up
okay
good i hope we will continue to inundate
ols with a request for amendments on
out of the chair
yes representative
thank you uh this is probably for ms
smarling do we have a conglomerate
amendment
incorporating all of these at this time
uh yes
no okay thank you
not from ols just an informal one for me
so okay that's i couldn't find it
no no no it's
sure
that's
and this is a lengthy
involved thing thank you
i'm impressed that we managed to get the
one for 58
on time
absolutely that was a lot of work for
them
yeah
anything else all right
we
can't really vote on this due to not
having the final amendment also the
uh
non-tremaine amendment is being heard
this afternoon
so i think we're done as a committee for
the uh
house
um just i will i'll be there in person
this afternoon
[Music]
because i have a conflict
very good i'll be there
okay thank you
if we have a moment madam chair one of
the issues where i haven't been able to
discuss it with you directly
up to this point is uh
i know you're aware of the fact that dr
has given us some additional language
and which she has discussed with you i'm
told uh and also with she has discussed
it with lindsay courtney she is here uh
that is to say dr warner is with us and
i'm wondering whether
that we can deal with this
reconsideration motion uh at this time
or when you would like to do it let's
put it that way
let's do it now
so representative
motion is
i move to reconsider on
uh that portion i don't have the thing
citation in front of me uh
for the bill with regard to telehealth
for psychologists
um
and we we had a a
successful committee vote but doctor but
we never got to dr warner's first
amendment
um
she i thought she was here and i was
trying to contact her she had to step
away at just the inopportune moment so
i'm moving reconsideration on that
particular item
that's
section
of senator 133
and we adopted an amendment that
talked the language about
the telepaths
and
[Music]
simply said that people that a temporary
emergency license can apply for a full
license
not creating a movement
is that
your understanding
that is my understanding madam chair and
as i say dr warner is with us right now
so she can testify to that if it's
if that meets with your approval
uh yes we need to repeat vote to
reconsider first
i understand that but i'm just pointing
out that this is an opportune moment if
it meets your approval
so
let's see what the sense of the
committee
okay thank you
i tried to get i tried to get the
documents
to you to all of you by last night so
that you'd have it as early as possible
this morning or very late last night i
apologize for it but
didn't have the language until late
myself
all right thank you
is there anyone who wishes to speak on
no it's a perfectly germane amendment as
i understand it the latest language that
um
take it instead of
removing the section of on telepasses it
leaves it there with an additional
section that says if you have an
emergency license you could be
essentially promoted to a telepath mine
was a technical question
it is fully german
no question about that
okay working on fellows
so i just need a clarification here
so
what we voted on i'm not sure when it
was
um
and it was the straw poll i think to to
be able to make the draft is we replaced
section 12
with something
related to emergency licenses
but now the suggestion is we want to
consider if we want to
do something different
keep the emergency but put the telepath
back in
essentially
anyone else questions comments
okay then the
motion on the floor is to reconsider our
vote
on section 12 where we adopted an
amendment
uh verbs that they're psychic
i don't see any further discussion
so if you want to if you
would follow the rule on the question of
reopening that decision
okay
representative right
yes
corporates yes representative pearson
representative
yes
representative lekkis yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey yes
representative lonzara yes
representative santo nestaso
yes
representative billy
yes representative show it
yes
is he muted
representative judy please unmute
yourself and turn your your video
on
his videos on
videos on
he seems to have
left i don't see him anymore all right
well that's fine
okay representative schmidt
schultz
no answer representative fellows
yes
representative pimentel
representative
excuse me representing the chair
no
representative judy's back
judy we didn't hear your vote on
i guess we're not going to okay he looks
frozen
yeah frozen in time
[Music]
majority so we are reconsidering the
okay ma'am chair i didn't speak to the
issue too much if i may be allowed to
just say
uh
this committee has been working real
hard uh with regard to a number of
issues uh that required hard work and
we've done hard and good work
and i i hope we'll have an opportunity
to improve this current uh section
excuse me improve this current section
by hearing from dr warner and the the
languages in front of the draft were
being worked on even as we speak so
we should have it some point by early
thank you
okay
by the way madam chair my internet
rebooted in the middle of that vote
obviously we're talking about it i would
have voted yes
it does not change the outcome so but
thank you for rejoining us
all right uh since representative
almost dr warner have her explain what's
[Music]
has to she's joining us and she has to
yes
yes dr warner you are
you're recognized you just have to
now she's still showing up in the
attendees list at the moment
well sorry i honored her at least once
she came over to the panelists but she
she's thank you she's with us now
hello
i
i very much appreciate the opportunity
to speak to the committee on this
amendment
executive
director lindsey courtney
had actually apologized to me for
skipping over our input as she was
putting it together and she and i
developed the amendment that's in front
of you she sent it to chairman um
maguire and um i'm dr debbie warner as
you know
from the board of psychologists they
have authorized me to speak for the
board
and i'm very happy to report to you
this amendment is
approved fully
by the board and also incorporates the
input from the work session that was
chaired by representative yakubovic and
previously and also has the oplc
input
we wanted to make sure in the latest
version which is advanced a little
further than the one that representative
schmidt was about to present last
tuesday
uh
this one has also a provision
to account for those directly
who have had emergency licenses
in psychology all this time
during the covid
pandemic
and there are over a thousand of those
psychologists
they as originally written this would
have been
well for them but if we added the
section that they would automatically
immediately be given a
telepath license as soon as this
legislation passes
and that that will help them continue
the work that they're doing and have
continuity of care
with the many patients whom they've seen
in new hampshire during this time
i just wanted to say there was one
question that had come up in several
discussions that i had with people
and that was what's the difference
between telemedicine and a full license
or basically those two types of practice
and they both must function under the
law
and i guess i have a good analogy for
you and that is that
riding a motorcycle follows the traffic
laws and so does driving a semi-tractor
trailer truck and yet we have different
licenses for them
during the pandemic
all of the psychologists in new
hampshire plus these emergency
psychologists
have been doing telemedicine and we have
developed uh quite a bit of um
have new habits and also understanding
of how
the rules and our practices our habits
translate into this medium
there have been many many
trainings on this and the list serves
among psychologists
are
full of discussion about this
and i believe that the psychologists who
have been granted entry uh to treat our
people in new hampshire
have likewise of course been involved in
this
up gearing the tune-up that we're
getting to make sure that we have full
practice um
adhesion
during our telemedicine sessions and
that the
the attention that that has gotten is
very very good
so we do feel confident that this
psychologists who have been granted
emergency licenses
will be able to function well with the
telepaths license
we are not um ready to grant full
licenses to everyone who has
been involved they would need to
follow
the
board's rules in order to get a full
license
we do have a process new hampshire has
laws and rules in every one of the
boards to get a license
uh however in these discussions
we are also already looking at our emerg
our application
rules they are already
fully parsed apart and we're working on
that already
and in this discussion it's brought
forward that much more simplification is
desirable and so as we are working
through this process with jlcarr and uh
certainly with input
we are very very welcome to have input
from all of you of how you would like us
to proceed forward with our general
license
but we are very comfortable and
confident that we can accommodate the
emergency licensees
into practice in new hampshire and this
gives sort of a sheltered landing
for them into full-time
permanent
practice and we're very comfortable with
that
i'll take questions you've all seen all
these materials that i've bombarded
everybody with so thank you
do we have questions
thank you
yes doctor
and i'm
i apologize because i was working on two
other bills with my own committee so i
printed out
your proposed amendment but couldn't go
through it
in depth
and i think i see what may be a conflict
on i guess you would say page one
uh down under section two
d it says
in accordance with board rules and
payment of license
fees
and then on the next page
the line under section 4c
any fees required to apply
is scratched out
so what exactly is the proposal for the
fees
oh that's taken out i'm sorry because
the board no longer sets their own fees
that's done in another section of live
believe it's
i
can't recall which section it is i'm
sorry but that's the one that has oplc
um the office of professional license
they set the fee so it's not in our
statute anymore
okay thank you so the other question you
had was in was it roman three i just
pulled up the
yes are you looking at parentheses f as
no
i'm sorry
it says um
parentheses c
okay
i'll stop that must be coming out of
your
specific um
designated fees
okay so this is
roman three
licensees shall i agree to conditions
including
and parentheses c
is that
they need to recognize that even if
they're in another state that they must
surrender to our request
to comply and that would be sufficient
cause if we send them
an order to send information or reply to
us or to appear
for a discipline hearing and such or
any of the things that are required in
our discipline process that
in fact ignoring that is also cause for
revocation we really want because
they're out of state
that they would
agree to comply with the power
of the regulatory authority to have them
bring in information
i really do appreciate the opportunity
to bring this forward it's it's very
all right then the
this language looks clean enough to be
inserted into the not yet final
amendment for senate bill 133
so
i believe the next thing to do
would be to vote on whether or not to do
so
what used to be romans 12 but probably
isn't anymore
with this language as provided by
um
question yes representative schmidt
uh well at this time it seems like a
motion
ought to pass would be appropriate
uh for our straw vote in any case
right
that's it okay so the motion is ought to
pass on this amendment to replace the
does do you wish to speak to your
amendment your motion representative
schmidt
i believe this isn't uh still a further
improvement in the already
improved version that we voted on
previously so uh
i hope
due to the fact that we are making a
sincere effort to try to do the best
things we can for our citizens and for
our professions
that uh if we can if we can make it
better and this does that we should
support it so thank you
representative
yes i will just say ditto to what he
said
and it really does um
provide some opportunities for folks in
any other comments questions
from sam blackis i'm still a little
fuzzy on this could someone in just a
few sentences give a summary of what
this change will do
it creates a new passive license
for out-of-state psychologists
to perform telehealth only
it gives the restrictions
that they need to
amendment versus what was already there
i forgot the difference between
the
and this says that anyone who has an
emergency license gets a telepath
to practice remotely
the previous amendment deleted all
all reference to a telepath and simply
said that you had an emergency license
eliminating that first the full
when you said intermediate this
intermediate is
replacing their full licensure correct
okay so it's a limitation it's a
limitation on the licenses of people who
got emergency licenses
and but on the other hand
it does give them a
a life a license even if it's limited to
temp
to
remote
action
seeing none the motion is to adopt this
amendment
into senate bill 1.
this is a strong poll of the edna
committee when adopting dr warner's
amendment as
to be included into our amendment for
senate bill 133 and this blessed by oplc
you're just blessed by oplc yeah
yes madame here
uh i'm sorry i lost contact twice so i
[Music]
very well could you speak up more
clearly
okay let me put my volume okay
yes dear madame chair
uh
[Music]
i really i lost contact twice
in the previous vote
so i try to call and i try to
raise my hands but
i didn't vote so i don't know what
you're going to do for that
well you are here now and thank you
we're glad to have you here
okay
okay the motion is to adopt this
amendment to our
final amendment to senate bill 133
made by representative schmidt and the
clerk
representative wright
yes
[Music]
yes representative pearson yes
representative yakovich
yes
allegro
representative lonzaro
yes
representative
uh yes i believe you called me i did
representative schultz
yes representative fellows
yes
representative pimentel
representative grota
yes
representative o'brien
the chair
no
okay we have um
all right motion is passes 17-2
uh ms marlin if you will send this
updated language to
oplc
i mean
sorry
uh one comment under roman five where it
says
people who have been granted emergency
licenses under the department of
emergency
shall be granted a telepath license i
think you will stay upon application to
they should have to take some action
to get the license
so yes i think it should be the board
okay
sure so this replaces
uh the current
on part
12.
right correct okay
whatever it may have been remembered but
it was it was roman 12.
okay
thank you everyone i'm sure dr warner is
grateful as well
thank you so much
so we have
uh
on the non-jermaine amendment this
afternoon
there is
going to be a we have an exact session
scheduled
for next tuesday
to cover
133 with the final amendment
assuming ols can come through with it
and
155. and
i believe
we discussed everything of 155 except
the non-german amendment and we seem to
be in fair agreement
so that should go smoothly
okay if you're not going to be here next
tuesday please let me know so i can
arrange for substitutes
and uh
that's it
thank you all for coming and
thank you everyone
resuming at 1 30 for the amendment
is now a good time to make the joke that
i thought we were voting on telepath not
telepaths
uh
okay
okay
okay
foreign
does anyone know i don't think we're
going to be executing anything at this
point i see that representative pimentel
well i have missed him and i'm glad he's
been with us i don't know that he
needs to sub for this part of
well i guess that's well i'm only here
because of the possibility
that you're going to be executing but if
that's not a possibility
i can uh just put one second again no i
mean yeah we could maybe do a softball
vote
on the amendment but we certainly can't
exactly
as well as i do that you want to come
yes us man i know
i have a lot of fun with you guys
sir i missed you i've missed you
it's bad we don't get to see each other
in the cafeteria either so yeah yeah
we've had lunch many times now
i was wondering today what happened to
elizabeth in her kitchen
oh yeah
um
i think these i don't know
i could find out though because my
friend is one of the cooks
so we are we are
temp we're going to just hang out for a
second we're waiting on representative
roy to chair this
yes i know he said he was coming into
person
please
it went to voicemail so i would hope so
so we're just going
before we start this
all right so if you're not going to need
me this afternoon then i will uh get out
of these clothes into my work clothes
and
do my yard work
rod i'm sure one of us could call or
text if there is
yeah i'll keep my uh i'll keep my phone
in my pocket
this is just caring i mean
separate from this amendment um
the stuff we agreed on earlier for 155
has to be merged together to
an official amendment
yeah we can't we can't exactly we're
still waiting for
we don't have the ability corrections
well there is this uh there is the bill
about the total destruction of the
universe we might want to examine
what's that that's the way to do issues
that would have solved a lot of problems
leaving us to go carry a bag in the
clubs and uh head on out doing some
other work uh we'll let you go well i
got yard work this afternoon but yeah i
do have a tea time for 5 20 at december
do you have his cell number jeff
yes he does
okay i do as well and you do as well all
right i probably do too but i just
it would be impossible if you don't have
but you can't exactly parts of a bill
when you're at the final point it's you
have to do the whole thing so that's
great
uh risk because rod penitent
was selling today for them this morning
but
they're going to cut them loose because
we might point out the typos to them
also
yeah
yeah this is definitely
this has titles in it so
what's the newest yep two of them
[Music]
i don't really want to get any of them
yeah me too in 1982.
while we're waiting i wanted to point
out it has been brought to my attention
that
um one of the folks who's testifying is
a physician who has
patients scheduled again starting at 3
15 if he could be
maybe
allowed to speak a little earlier and
that's dr raymond walston i believe
so just putting that
out there
did you get that air injected shot did
you have a scar
yeah yeah
[Music]
anyway
the script should be in the file in the
the
burgundy file folder
and mr chairman also we've we've got um
dr beth daly i don't believe is on the
registration sheet but she is
here from the bureau of infectious
disease control you know new hampshire
dhhs and she
um
speak gonna mute your um machine mr
chairman
okay we're gonna um begin the hearing
on the non-domain amendment to sp 155
i'm going to start off with our scripts
and as chair of
the committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the government as
a result of covert 19 pandemic in
accordance with house rule 67 in the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically please note that
there is no physical location for the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to the meeting however
in accordance with the emergency order i
am confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoo electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a anyone who
has a problem accessing this meeting
or email
s
l e g dot state
dot nh dot us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled please note
that all votes that are taken during the
meeting shall be done by roll call
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call of attendance when each member
states they're present please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during the meeting which is required
under the rights no longer
[Music]
mr chair it's faster to do this than to
argue the point but this is a recessed
hearing i don't know why we're doing any
i think this is actually a new amendment
it doesn't matter it's recessed hearing
representative allegro
president in the room
representative bailey present in the
neither is representative from
representative goalie
at home and my wife is in the other room
representative grota
i'm in my home office alone
no answer representative lonzara
hi home in nashua and some family
throughout representative lekkis
president in the committee room
uh representative mcguire is not here
representative o'brien
i'm present
in nashua
and home alone
representative pearson i am president in
the community
representative roy i am here
representative center nostals
i'm here alone
representative schmidt
i am home in my home office in dover and
i'm alone
representative short
i am here in my home in pembroke
representative schultz
i'm in my home in concord and my husband
gene taylor will be in and out of the
room
the clerk is in the room
let's count the abs well we we don't
need it forms
all right
thank you
all right um before i begin the hearing
i just want to remind everyone this is a
public hearing um the purpose of this
hearing is to enlighten the committee on
issues we may or may not be aware of so
that we may better make a decision
um members
are cautioned against arguing with
witnesses
we've already got your type questions
i'd like to keep the testimony to a
minimum we have two sheets full of
people wishing to testify and i'd like
to make sure the public has an
opportunity to be heard
so if we could keep the questions and
responses
to a minimum i'd appreciate it i'm not
going to put any limit on it at this
time but that may change as the hours
wear on
i have been aware of several witnesses
wishing to testify who have hard stops
we'll start with representative schultz
could you please tell me the name of the
person that had to get out quickly
it is a
a physician let me find his name again
um
i apologize i was just texting dr
walston
thank you and he
just needs to go before i think 3 15 so
okay so we're gonna go we've got two
others we're gonna have to go by 2 30 so
we'll take them first and then that
person so we're going to start man
mr chair yes ma'am go ahead please
represent us
um
if i may ask uh are you not
the sponsor of this amendment
i am the sponsor of the amendment yes
i believe as the sponsor you should not
restricted from the
i think as long as i don't question
anybody
generally if
if you are the sponsor you don't even
sit at the table you usually sit
at the
other end of the room
desk
it's an official household that seems to
happen
yeah
well
we're short on bodies
i uh we don't need a quorum for a
hearing so
i'm sorry but representative roy we have
historically this this
this committee has always
followed this rule
any bills where the sponsor is either at
a public hearing
the sponsor
does not sit at the table with the
committee members
i'm sorry that i just think we need to
[Music]
mr chair would you like me to contact
house clerk paul smith and and
yeah just if he's readily available just
to ask if because it's an amendment
right right
i'll i've got his cell phone number and
hopefully i'll be able to get him
quickly well make sure to mention that
it's a non-germane
amendment because that makes it really
[Music]
while we're waiting mr chair uh if i
might
um the uh
objection that's been raised i believe
is correct i don't think it's important
with whether whether you're sitting at
the table or not but uh i i don't
believe you should be chairing the
meeting under the circumstances however
i'm completely comfortable with
representative lekkis or representative
uh
pearson they've chaired the committee in
the past
um
and
it's facilitating the meetings what it's
all about so i'm comfortable with
representative blechus taking over
rather than wasting precious time uh
hearing back from the clerk mr chairman
[Music]
yes go ahead representative
just so we can move things along i just
uh i was on the phone i called the clerk
before this meeting started just to
confirm we were all set with you being
in the chair
um he said you know generally
a sponsor shouldn't share but uh being
an amendment yeah you were allowed to
chair
um he said just that you need to make
sure that there's no questioning on your
behalf or any of that going forward that
you just call ahead on the speakers and
facilitate the meeting
and i believe that
um chairman mcguire uh shared that
opinion so i'm just gonna go ahead and
um
and i will play referee and not ask any
questions
um until right here yep i have no
problem with that all right thank you
representative
okay so um back of business we're going
to start with
[Music]
yes
would you like me to um promote somebody
if you would that would be helpful
because the list is huge since it's
taken me too long to go through it i'm
looking for ryan cole i believe
yes i've got him he raised his hand so
he was at the top
i'm here thank you
okay um you may go ahead and unmute and
proceed
[Music]
thank you mr chair and uh thank you to
everybody for allowing me to be here um
by way of disclosure i have no
disclosures
um i belong to no political party i'm an
independent scientist i'm a mayo clinic
triple board mayo clinic trained triple
boarded pathologist i've seen 350 000
patients in my career i have phd
background in immunology
i am not anti-vaccine at all i've had
all my vaccines not this one as have my
children had all their vaccines so
that's my disclosure
i know the issue at hand today is
mandatory vaccines
these are currently per the emergency
authorization of the fda these are
investigational
and i don't think we're emphasizing that
enough
these are per the fda optional
and per the
section 21 of the code of federal
regulations an experimental
medicine or vaccine cannot be mandated
by federal law
um
[Music]
it's interesting we're currently
conducting the largest experiment on
humanity
with something that is only emergency
authorized these are not approved these
are not licensed and in the eua
approvals it clearly states that these
are not indicated uh for any condition
actually which is which is interesting
to read
um the
um use of these excessively on a
population without long-term safety data
is technically a violation of the
nuremberg code
for the which we know what happened to
the doctors in germany after the
nuremberg trials
the other
point i would like to bring up this is
technically by trying to mandate a
vaccine it's a public health hazard
because it decreases confidence when
something has to be mandated it
decreases the public's confidence in
that
in that
drug in that vaccine in that modality
this happened in the philippines several
years ago with the dengue vex
where a lot of children were injured and
after that the public confidence and
vaccination went from 88 down to in the
high 20s low 30 percent
so
you know it to to mandate something with
no long-term safety data is technically
you know in terms of the vaccine those
who have wanted or needed the vaccine
that are in the high risk group have had
it
so
the vaccine is to protect you from a
virus
and under you know the age of 65 this is
a
99.99 survivable virus this becomes even
less than a flu
death rate if you look at the infection
fatality rate so we're looking at some
thing that obviously was scary at first
we used the precautionary principle but
this is something now that we know that
the the risk age for death from this
virus and complications are age 65 and
older and those in that cohort of
individuals have had the opportunity to
receive this vaccine so far
now the one thing i think that we're
missing is if we look at the vaccine
adverse events reporting system
there are over 4 000 deaths associated
that are under investigation from the
vaccine itself that's more individuals
potentially
dead from a vaccine than from 911 itself
there are over 100 point of order mr
chairman
[Music]
uh the doctor is speaking about a
non-existent situation there is no
mandate under discussion
the bill of the non-german amendment is
a ban on vaccine passports and a ban on
mandate there are no mandates or vaccine
passports
schmidt the testimony is jermaine
and i'm going to allow it thank you
please continue talking thank you mr
chair
um
so eight out of eight out of ten deaths
in north america have been in the
high-risk
category so
to to either mandate a vaccine or to
require a passport for something that is
in the younger age cohort more
survivable than
um
you know an average flu season
doesn't seem medically
prudent in any way shape or form and
these vaccines additionally they didn't
submit to the fda their actual relative
risks their data points that are
supposed to be submitted to the
government to approve vaccines they
submitted their relative risks and the
fda violated its own rule
in
giving authorization to these the
absolute relative risk tells us that
120-ish people for the pfizer vaccine
would have to get both shots for one
person to have one less symptom
so we're
attributing to an experimental modality
that is technically at this point just
decreasing symptoms
uh and not providing you know
technically a full immunity as we've
seen ten or thousands of breakthrough
cases post-vaccine so
to require um
a vaccine or require a vaccine or a
passport or anything of that sort you
know this this is an experiment and
these these
have led to death hundreds of thousands
of adverse events and
we are pushing them forward as though
they're an approved product they
absolutely are not
and then the other thing we're ignoring
is how many of us that have already in
our society had covid kovid provides the
broadest
most natural immunity of all studies out
of israel show that those who have had
covet have an equal if not better
immunity
to um
you know to cover than you know the
vaccine
so uh
the other thing we're ignoring is how
many people actually have antibodies how
many people have a t cell response how
many people
if we look at the numbers within the
states your state as well
is very similar to my state presently
you know only a handful hundred two
hundred at most uh positive um cases per
day were down at an endemic level and uh
you know were
close to getting back to functional if
we actually look at the data
compared to the fears which we should be
overcoming by this point
um i know dr norcasm's here i
greatly admire and i hope he will talk
to the concept of screening before the
vaccine because we're putting a lot of
people at risk with vaccines
if we don't test to see if they have
cobit presently have had covet or have
antibodies ramping up so we're putting a
lot of our population at risk for
something that we
essentially as most of the nation have
gotten through already and we're getting
into
a good uh level and health point and
we're ignoring critical public health
messages
in terms of how to you know really
prevent covert and that's maintaining
our
our metabolic health as the nation our
low vitamin d levels our obesity
pandemic
our
bad food system our our sugars our
inflammatory diets and that should be a
strong public health message
rather than you know have you had a shot
do you need a pass to have you had a
shot
you know it's that
children survive this at a hundred
percent rate statistically age 0 to 18.
our college-age students
140 000 patients in one study last year
were
out of 140 000 there were 17
hospitalizations
all of those
those had risk factors no deaths at that
point in a large study so we are looking
at this in an incorrect um medical
manner we've politicized something that
from a medical point of view we
understand very well now
and we know the risk groups they have
been vaccinated
they are protected
we don't need to be pushing for
an experiment on humanity with unknown
outcomes and with the history of
coronaviruses
prior to this we have never had a
coronavirus vaccine because we have
known that they lead to the hyperimmune
reactions down the road it's called an
antibody dependent enhancement reaction
we don't know if that's going to happen
with this one with my immunology
training there are five or six
mechanisms that can trigger this once
the virus becomes different enough and
we get exposed to it years from now
which could cause untold havoc if we
push too much vaccination
oh absolutely okay absolutely
representative schmidt would you like to
ask a question related to what you had
happy to
to to to challenge the premise under
which dr cole is testifying
[Music]
mr chair i'm happy to do that
okay
representative schultz thank you
thank you mr chair and i did hear your
point about wanting to keep the q a
parts brief i will have that goal
through this whole game
uh feel free to call me out of order
it's kind of fun okay
nice to meet you dr cole
are you aware that
the very well respected factcheck.org
run by the annenberg
center which is a nonpartisan
journalism school
has actually fact checked a speech you
gave with all the same or similar points
uh at the in idaho at the um invitation
of the lieutenant governor i believe
they fact checked all the things that
you're saying and in fact determine that
to be woefully
um untrue are you aware of the annenberg
factcheck.org
we seem to be accusing the uh witness of
uh spreading misinformation
perhaps even willfully
i would say that that is very germane in
this situation because
a respected independent fact check group
has determined his views
i'm going to allow the uh
the question just um
only because it seems to me you're
trying to solicit whether or not the
good doctor is aware of a counter study
but um
just be careful about challenging his
intent
thank you i will
i'm quite a uh thank you representative
schultz yes i'm quite aware of that
factcheck.org
i spoke spoke with a reporter i gave her
all my articles and counterpoints she
did not publish all the articles and
counterpoints i had my medical evidence
that i did present to her they do have
their bias most certainly as well as
they're funded by
the vaccine industry so fact checking
the fact checkers yes they have funding
from the vaccine industry so there's
their fact check is with not without
bias itself and as i said i'm not
affiliated with any party i'm not
affiliated with any political
organization and i did respond to them
and i wish that they would have actually
put the medical data with which i
responded which would have been the
ethical the proper
and the kind thing to do i'm i'm willing
to be uh challenged on any point i bring
up i have the science behind what i
state i have no ulterior motive other
than the wellness and the health of our
society your state my state and our
great nation thank you
mr chair just one quick follow-up
the one i'm citing is the annenberg um
organization
are you saying that they're funded by um
vaccine
pharma type organizations because my
impression of black group is it's
independent
of any influence
not true actually part of their funding
comes from the robert wood johnson
foundation
of the which one of their executives is
a former um
uh pharmaceutical representative vaccine
representative and they get a good
percentage of their funding from that
group so they're not without ties
thank you
uh representatives
thank you mr chair i would like to ask
that um you limit
the speakers to three minutes of
testimony and then give us time for
questions
and also for all those out there waiting
to speak i would hope that they speak
specifically to this bill i don't think
we need a lesson about um viruses or
the coba virus or any virus in general i
think that they should be speaking
directly to
the benefits or the um
detrimental effects of this bill
all right
i would say that it's pretty much
impossible to not talk about the
virus that causes the need for a vaccine
but your point is well taken and i'm
trying to keep an eye on the time limits
i believe that the doctor didn't take
more than three minutes um oh i'm quite
sure he did
well
we'll agree to disagree uh do you have a
no that was what i wanted to say all
right thank you for taking the time to
testify doctor
mr norcasm
dr norcasm
yes hello
um mr chairman members of the committee
um i'm privileged and humbled uh to rise
before you here um representing um
the great people of the state of new
hampshire and in support of sv155
against the vaccine mandates
specifically in your state so i
appreciate this invitation my name is
human norchasm i'm a physician
immunologist and a public health
advocate in the philadelphia area in the
state of pennsylvania
and by way of background
i
completed a an md and a phd degree at
the university of pennsylvania
school of medicine under a medical
scientist training program grant from
the nih
i subsequently
served as a principal investigator on
immunology research grants at the nih
and i've served on the faculty of
medical schools at penn harvard and
thomas jefferson university in
philadelphia
and i want to start by stating that
i am a very very strong supporter of
this vaccine i believe this vaccine
technology
is uh one of the most remarkable
achievements of immunological science
in the recent past
i do believe that it is my personal
opinion
that
we ought to be offering this vaccine
to as many uh non-immune americans as is
possible as quickly as possible so we
can get a handle on this pandemic
so without a question as an immunologist
that is my opinion about the vaccine and
about its efficacy
of course i have stated some concerns
about safety and that's available in the
public press and i invite you to
listen to those interviews and opinions
that i've stated
i would like to make three points
specifically vis-a-vis this this bill uh
specifically focused on the idea of
mandating vaccination
uh the first point that i'd like to
bring to your attention for
consideration is that
um i you know i don't believe it's a
tenable position for a state
to allow private corporations businesses
and academic institutions to force or
coerce in any way citizens into
undergoing any kind of medical treatment
at risk to their civil liberties or
educational opportunities
i i know that this would be a violation
of a
core medical principle of autonomy and
very certainly i believe
that that the legal experts will will
inform you that it also will likely be a
breach of the united states constitution
herself
the second point is uh something that dr
cole
alluded to and this is something that
i've been advocating with the cdc
for quite some time and with the fda
which is that at present about 20 30
percent of our fellow americans are
already naturally immune and from an
immunological perspective
including the emerging data from israel
as well as prior studies these already
infected people um actually have a quite
substantial amounts of protective
antibodies the same kind of antibodies
that the vaccine induces in them and so
they are they stand to gain marginally
or uh not at all and therefore this uh
medical procedure in them would be an
unnecessary one because these folks will
already be immune and that's about one
out of four americans right so i will
state to this committee with 100
certainty that mandating such
unnecessary or marginally beneficial
medical treatments
in a one-size-fits-all fashion as we're
doing as the cdc is promoting is really
the recipe for causing irreparable
medical harm in some unsuspecting
citizens of your state and across the
country so i would really urge you to
think about that concept very very
carefully the third point is these
vaccine mandates i believe will be an
absolute disaster for civil rights and
equity and inclusion things that we
should all care about you have to
recognize that the same socio-economic
demographics in our nation who suffer
disproportionately from a lack of access
to everything from health care to
adequate voting rights will be made to
suffer more using any sort of cumbersome
vaccine mandate these vaccine mandates
are not going to be trivial to uh
introduce to people with disparities and
socioeconomic despair disparities so in
summary what i'd like to
clarify in this record for you is my
strong opposition to vaccine mandates
not to the vaccine itself this vaccine
needs to be deployed efficiently into
people who need it myself i have i've
been vaccinated my teenage children have
been vaccinated my elderly parents have
been vaccinated i believe in this
vaccine and i know the technology that
it's based on but i think these mandates
will be a disaster and that they'll
promote irreparable medical harm and
inequities to minority subsets of
unsuspecting citizens around the country
and some of them some of these folks
will be some of the weakest amongst us
so i strongly urge you to support sb155
um
in in um
opposition to these mandates and to uh
consider very carefully that the
solution to um these these ideas of
vaccine hesitancy is actually to respect
individual choices respect individual
americans and to respect the science the
truth and healing in our nation is going
to come in the center not in in a
polarized discourse as i see it right
now there's tremendous polarization on
this idea some people believe this this
vaccine does not work that it's that
it's some sort of mind control device
that bill gates has designed right and
some people some people uh believe that
we should just give put it into anyone
you know i i have never heard of a
medical treatment ever
that is uh devoid of some some rate of
complication and to assume that this
particular medical therapy is going to
have no complications associated is a
mistake to assume that we can give it to
people who don't need it and not expect
harm is unreasonable it is a violation
of medical ethical principles to give
people who are already immune
a therapy that they do not stand to
benefit from and the data on that is
going to be
unassailable both from a scientific
prognostication perspective as well as
from the clinical trials emerging from
places like israel and the united
kingdom so i would urge you to encourage
the cdc and the public health
departments to really
not mandate this to aim for education
public education as well as to really
ask the cdc whether already immune
people need this vaccine
thank you doctor will you entertain
questions
talk to me and say questions
of course yes
thank you mr chair and
thank you doctor for taking my question
uh one of your statements that you had
made was that
uh
businesses forcing vaccines on their
workers
uh could be unconstitutional
um could you explain to me how that
would happen when currently schools uh
k-12 are allowed to require vaccinations
for students um and to my knowledge that
has not been found unconstitutional that
why
a business or a pub college would be
found unconstitutional for sure uh mr
goldie i'm not an i'm not an attorney
and i if you if you noted i um um i um
qualified that by saying almost
certainly i reached the united states
constitution i think anytime you use
coercion
you know anytime you sort of use a
mechanism where where
which is designed to curtail
the uh capacity of a citizen to engage
in employment or educational
opportunities yeah you have to wonder
whether that action actually stands in
the face of the united states
constitution so in other words if we if
we are going to put into place
mechanisms that would curtail the
opportunity of of individual citizens to
um to employment to the basically the
pursuit of life um
and life uh and and liberty i i i think
you have to question whether that goes
against the grain of our constitution uh
perhaps it goes against the grain of our
ethos uh it certainly should so i think
that you know right now we're dealing
with a with a very uncertain situation a
lot of people are operating based on
fear and i think a lot of those fears
are are irrational and unreasonable i
don't think we can disrespect that i i
think we if
we disrespect this concept that there
are many folks about 50 of the country
who either have doubts about this
vaccine or are hesitant i think this is
going to backfire so my my suggestion to
you respectfully is that um you know if
the lawyers tell you that it's not
unconstitutional
i would say that it goes against the
american ethos and it goes against the
basic fundamental you know principles of
human decency to to threaten someone by
with this concept that they can't get
educated or they can't or they can't you
know make a living or they can't have a
job because they're not going to get a
vaccine
i i don't think this is right i i think
i think we're going to we're going to
make a very big mistake i mean it's
going to turn into a draconian thing
where about 50 of the country half of
our politics is basically shoving some
something down people's throats where
where they just don't want it and and
that's just
really good that's the against the grain
of being american frankly thank you okay
follow up
yes
just to clarify that you believe it
should be fun
unconstitutional but it isn't
unconstitutional as of what we know
right now
i'm not a i'm not an attorney uh i'm
just suggesting that maybe because
certainly it's a violation of medical
ethics to force anyone to do anything
including getting vaccinated
that's my
uh representative schultz
i'd love to keep talking about that but
i want to ask you a separate question
related to what you've said because it's
interesting that you say you actually
support the
you like this vaccine you've gotten this
vaccine it's not that it's not that i
like it representative it's that i know
the immunology behind it when i was in
graduate school it was being developed i
know the technology it works very well
uh you know you can't you can't you
can't argue no one can argue against you
know neutralizing igg antibodies and
prime t cells these antibodies are going
to be protected and isn't this our um rm
mrna
vaccine technology it is actually not
new haven't we been researching this
since
maybe the late 90s yes
20 plus years this technology is about
30 years old it's been in the pipelines
of academia and industry this is not a
new technology however that doesn't
override the fact that the vast majority
of the public aren't familiar with it
like for example you can you remember
when the cell phones first came out
right people thought they were going to
walk around with brain cancer right i
mean the technology for cell phones was
in the pipelines of the department of
defense and academia for two decades
before the marketplace saw it so i think
a lot of the fears of this vaccine are
irrational at the same time at the same
time we got to be very careful about
mandating anything because you know you
know our our democracy is you know
we're not a theocracy we're not we're
not a totalitarian system we have to
respect people's individual um
understanding and meet them where they
are so this vaccine mandate is going to
be an absolute disaster from that
perspective i appreciate you answering
my question my pleasure representative
[Music]
thank you mr chair
um yes doctor if
um
if i understood you correctly you said
that
approximately 20 to 30 percent of
americans
have a natural immunity
is there a simple
inexpensive efficient way
to test that
yes thank you representative for asking
this so first of all the data that i'm
quoting comes from the from the red
cross the red cross recently published a
study that that demonstrated that
somewhere around 20 this is several
months ago so about 20 of americans were
donating blood actually uh were uh
positive for antibodies and those are
the folks who are immune those are the
people who are donating convalescent
plasma and incidentally we are mandating
those folks to get vaccinated too in
some places right so we're actually
taking their plasma to use to treat
people who are infected but at the same
time we're required to get vaccinated so
it doesn't jive but but you know i have
to say that the 20 number comes from
there and yes in fact the antibody tests
are quite uh vastly available every
corner lab core um across the country
and what i've been advocating is this
concept of screen before vaccine and
i've been in direct communication with
dr janet woodcock
at the fda about this that this idea
that we can actually if we can put a
rover on mars we can certainly get
americans especially high-risk americans
just get screened before vaccination and
only deliver this vaccine when it's
medically necessary you know and i have
no objection to getting this vaccine
into younger kids but as i said my
teenagers have gotten it my younger kids
will probably get it when it becomes
available but you know i think this idea
of putting this vaccine into people who
don't need it is absurd it's completely
absurd it's it's a dramatic error in in
regulatory policy at the level of the
fda and the cdc and we should all fight
it both parties this is this is going to
hurt people
thank you uh follow up question
uh go ahead
yes uh
this is a question i have curiosity for
mr
norsham and for mr cole
you had signed in on the
sheet to testify
and you showed your title as an elected
official
did you perhaps choose the wrong
category or what office are you elected
to oh i i apologize i i don't know i uh
a representative uh lawsec
from the state of
new hampshire
invited me to this i never signed up on
anything some that must be an error i'm
not an elected official i'm a physician
and an enologist and a public health
advocate in philadelphia
all right and is that true of uh mr cole
also
we know
he's no longer here so
representative schultz
thank you mr chair this will be quick um
you know the the antibody test um that
you
are mentioning the concern i have
because i don't think you are in new
hampshire you know certainly we're very
fiscally responsible here as i'm sure
you know
isn't that an expensive process
wouldn't it uh comparing the safety and
the cost
um wouldn't it be actually more
reasonable to just you know
vaccinate everybody but the isn't that
antibody test
expensive um so so um representative
schultz you know i think that um the the
idea here is that that we have to decide
whether does every american life matter
or not number one and number two whether
we agree with the idea of medical
necessity so in other words are we going
to do things to people who need them or
stand to benefit from them or not right
and if the answer to both those
questions is yes every single american
matters and b
yes we're not going to do anything
that's that's unnecessary or marginally
beneficial to people then the question
becomes how do we implement it so people
can have access look we built millions
of respirators at the on the front end
of this thing we activated the defense
production act right the reality is that
this thing this antibody test is already
in the supply chain around the country
almost every american has insurance
access many americans itself pay for
this i mean you know in most
metropolitan areas and even in most
rural areas there are lab wars within a
10-mile radius of everyone now if
president biden and and the democrats in
the white house and again this is not a
partisan thing i think we should all
come together on this right
if if there's willingness and capacity
to activate at a federal level then
absolutely yes and we can risk stratify
who needs it and who doesn't so for
example if you're in an institution if
you're like in a geriatrics institution
you know you're at high risk of having
the vaccine but if you're a suburban
soccer mom right you may be at low risk
you may just need to have a choice but
you know if you remember the military
service if you're if you're in a
congested area say in north philly right
where you're actually at high risk you
know to not screen folks and and exclude
people who are already immune is a
massive error the other dimension of
this representative schultz i wanted to
mention is that you know
getting the vaccine to americans is one
thing right but the reality is that
places like brazil and and india are the
breeding ground for new variants right
we should really focus some of our
activity and actions to delivering this
vaccine to the rest of the world now one
one pathway is to use intellectual
property to relax intellectual property
rights the other is to say hey wait a
minute we have like
you know an additional 100 or 200
million vaccine shots in america who
aren't necessary which aren't necessary
for people are already immune why don't
we share these with our partners and
allies right why don't we get out of our
own bubble right and actually look at
the global picture and say hey wait a
minute look people are in india like dr
are dropping like flies why are vaccines
to americans who don't need it and again
i would suggest you that this is not a
partisan issue i know i'm here on behalf
of the republican side and advocating
for this bill but really unless we can
find the center unless we can somehow
have you know uh get out of this sort of
one-size-fits-all approach which is
where harm lives and i want to also
reiterate to the committee an example
and i don't mean to take too much time
but look i'm going to have to go ahead
and cut you off here um we're running
really low on
yeah no problem you know the example i
wanted to use was how medicine has
become increasingly personalized mr
chairman and you know to to give up that
idea of personalization of medicine is a
mistake that's where harm is going you
know i lost my own wife to that exact
catastrophe there was a medical
procedure that was being applied to
women in a one-size-fits-all fashion
when we do that in medicine we end up
killing people unjustifiably we can't do
that
thank you for your testimony
okay
next up i'm going to call
dr
lawson
hello thank you chair um
i would say that uh my i don't have any
disclosures or anything like that can
you hear me okay
yes
okay um i don't have any disclosures or
anything of the sort i'm a pediatrician
i'm at dartmouth hitchcock um who wanted
to speak today um and i'd say largely i
do agree with dr um north chasm that uh
i don't think that any one thing is
applicable to everything um that being
said
um i have been doing some recent
research funded by the state of new
hampshire so thank you for that on
pediatric causes um
or cancer causes for the pediatric
population and risk factors associated
with it i'm in doing some of that
article research and review
there's one
thing that we have found that is not
like positive so much as preventative
and that is vaccines as a whole in
general
and so
just kind of that being said
vaccines overall that have been approved
and
fda kind of screened have generally been
overall and that are here in the united
states have been improvements for
children's health um
and in the past when we've had
incidences of decreased stringency with
vaccines
in certain states
like texas california florida even here
in new hampshire we've had increase in
health concerns and health costs such as
with measles outbreaks and whooping
cough or pertussis outbreaks
and so i think that's something to kind
of keep in mind um and my kind of whole
purpose and
intent behind you know
discussing this is ultimately i'm
pediatrician i know no offense to the
adults but i care about kids
and we as adults can help take care of
kids
by getting vaccinated um
one big kind of uh take-home point that
i have to describe that
and how vaccines are helpful for the
sickest to kids um is that here at
dartmouth we had a patient who's you
know had leukemia um getting treated on
chemo had no immune system because he
had just finished his last dose of chemo
everything was finished and he was going
home
but then ended up getting an infection
from a vaccine preventable disease
and eventually overtook his body and he
succumbed to the age of four
secondary to a disease that could be
prevented by
you know getting vaccines
and so ultimately uh i agree with dr
north chasm is that you know people have
the right to decide but i also think
that
we as a public have the right to take
care of and you know
should be taking care of
those who can't take care of themselves
like children um
and so you know taking care of those you
know little four-year-olds who can't
have an immune response and by
you know encouraging others to get the
vaccine is highly uh beneficial to that
population in addition to
those that whether it be cancer or chemo
we just don't have a great immune
thank you um we take questions
absolutely i'm representative schultz
thank you mr chair and thank you dr
walston for all that you're doing
[Music]
um
here in new hampshire
for the kids
my question is
uh it is
something that
concerns some folks
is the fact that schools mandate certain
vaccines and that's
certainly the university system which i
guess
those folks technically most of them are
not children but
uh similarly some of our public
universities are requiring
the vaccine um
for students to return to in-person
learning
um
do you
think that um
causes a problem
or does this
constitute having this mandate for kids
in schools or young adults in the
university
post-secondary schooling
causes any difficulty or problem
so i think that
there's a little bit of difference in
the like kind of two parts of that
question in that um
yeah there are mandatory vaccines
required for you know public school
universities and um you know public
education system but i think that's
that's just what it is is the public
education system and so that's you know
the public the state um wherever it is
saying that these
vaccines are required to maintain a
general um healthy public as deemed by
you know government the state
um and if you don't want your child to
have to get
um certain vaccines but they're required
at you know public schools then there
are private institutions that you know
are more welcome and opening to that um
they just understand that by opening
that they're increasing the potential
and risk for infections in their
population now that in the setting of
covet vaccine so uh i would agree with
the previous um two speakers that the
uh covet vaccine is largely not as
beneficial for younger patients and that
so much other people around them being
vaccinated is more beneficial because
while they're
not true
and the fact that we have had patients
pass away um with kovid
it is
not necessarily it is definitely not as
common as an older population however
the most important point being that with
kovid you know we're looking at the
whole picture not just individual you
know young patients versus old patients
and so i think that with that if you
have a
younger patient who needs a vaccine to
go to school
i'm not as concerned for that as opposed
to the people who they're going to share
the infection with if that makes sense
so the
young young
adult and adolescent population have
been shown to be the most kind of uh
carriers um so to speak of the vaccine
and so when they go home to their you
know elderly families and things like
that they're the ones that are most
likely going to suffer from it and so as
far as
the age gap and
recommendations i think that we still
have we're still getting a lot of
information i know that dr cole said
that you know we know this you know we
know a lot about this now and we
definitely know more about it now than
we did but we definitely don't know a
lot about it there's still a lot of
things we need to learn about the
vaccine and not just that not another
vaccine the virus but in addition to
that
how it's affecting people um and not
just
in certain kind of isolated situations
there's
thousands of
millions of dollars spent on research
for individual things one at a time and
we have you know a section of
information on this for the last year
and a half
but that's you know pretty minuscule
comparative to other diseases and
processes that we've studied so i think
there's a lot of learning to do on that
i hope that answered your question
thank you thank you so much
representative pearson
thank you i have a question actually
about the bill
so
doctor do you think that it's
appropriate
or
or even reasonable for the a person or
the government to ask
another person or to discriminate
against those individuals based on their
vaccine status or immunity status when
it comes to matters of public
accommodation
um i think that depends
so i i would agree with
norchasm in that you you can't you
globally group people together
and so if you say no we're not going to
you know provide services to any one
person because they don't have an immune
status i think that that's wrong because
certain like like you said certain
people don't need it because they're
they're you know got it already and we
could be using those resources elsewhere
or
you're at the risk of sharing that
infection with other people
so
to answer your question no i don't think
that it should be and i think that any
one kind of direction or the other is
trying to make it like a more partisan
and i agree it needs to be more centered
thank you
they're seeing none thank you for your
time doctor
thank you
mr chairman could could dr daley um
speak next
absolutely uh can you promote him
or
great well good afternoon everyone thank
you for allowing me to speak today i'm
beth daly i'm the bureau chief for
infectious disease control here
at new hampshire dhhs and i'm here to
provide testimony in opposition to this
amendment first i just quickly wanted to
address cover 19 vaccines specifically
to remind you all that there are no
legal requirements for coven 19 vaccine
in new hampshire and you've heard some
testimony from people promoting
pseudoscience what sounds like science
but it does not represent real science
and i don't want you all to forget that
there are still over 300 people that are
dying in the united states each day from
cove at 19. and this number was over 3
000 each day
if you could refrain from characterizing
the testimony of previous witnesses
as pseudoscience just stick to what you
know
thank you
the number of deaths was over 3 000 each
day prior to the availability of vaccine
and among these deaths have been around
500 children who have died from covet
19.
it's not true that thousands of people
have not died from the vaccine so i do
think it's within my realm of my
testimony to tell you when things are
not true it's not true and it's
dangerous to imply or say otherwise
i'm going to go broader than covet 19
vaccine though because we're quite
concerned that these amendments are
reaching beyond covet 19 we're very
concerned about any restrictions on
existing vaccination requirements such
as those that are in place for schools
and certain types of healthcare
employment
because vaccine coverage is not 100 nor
are vaccines 100 effective vaccine
requirements are essential to the health
and safety of our communities letting
children attend school without regard to
vaccination status will set us back over
100 years before we had safe and
effective vaccines when millions of
children were infected and disabled by
vaccine preventable diseases and
thousands died each and every year we
have an obligation to protect our
citizens and this amendment is dangerous
and i don't think our state wants to
take these steps backwards
we also have concerns regarding the
prohibitions on documenting vaccination
status documenting vaccination status is
an important obligation for schools
employers and public health this
information is critical to protecting
the public from vaccine preventable
diseases
and it's also in the best interest of
the people documenting vaccination
status is part of an infectious disease
investigation so there's a number of
diseases that require quarantine if
you've been exposed including covin-19
however if you're vaccinated and you
have an exposure you do not need to
quarantine after that exposure if an
employer or school or the health
department is not allowed to ask a
person's vaccination status the default
will be to exclude the exposed person
rather than allowing them to work if
they have been fully vaccinated and this
will unnecessarily keep people out of
work in school
furthermore the state of new hampshire
and health care providers administering
vaccine are required to document
information for every person who has
received a copic 19 vaccine
this is required under federal law and
we're not able to access coven 19
vaccine if we do not comply with this
lastly i want to point out that this
amendment conflicts with several
existing state laws including school and
child care vaccine entry and the
immunization registry laws
our goal through our immunization policy
is to provide public health protection
while also appropriately balancing
individual choice and under existing law
people already have a choice whether to
be vaccinated
and this amendment would then be
unnecessary and not in the best interest
thank you doctor any questions for dr
daler
uh representative stewart
thank you mr chair uh
and of the population of
new hampshire are all that choose to be
vaccinated
we could get into a situation where
folks who for medical reasons
cannot take the vaccine
would be higher risk because they would
say go grocery shopping and at that
point most likely no one would be
wearing masks anymore or very few
uh and they would therefore have
the
added risk of exposure not knowing
i'm sorry representative because the
very first part of your sentence cut out
i don't know if it did for others could
you just repeat the first part
yes i'm sorry
um i'm i'm saying that
if say 50 percent
of the citizens of new hampshire decide
not to be vaccinated but 50 or so are
then there are a percentage of citizens
we know who cannot
take the vaccine for medical reasons
would they not be at higher risk to go
about in public
as it would likely end up with
very few people wearing masks and
protecting others
if this becomes the the norm
yes thank you so that's correct that is
why there are immunization requirements
in place for schools for example there
are a number of very vulnerable
children who can have permanent
disability and die if they get a vaccine
preventable disease but some of them
aren't actually able to get vaccinated
due to their own health conditions and
so they rely on high rates of immunity
and the people around them uh to protect
them from getting these these vaccines
that's all sorry from getting these
diseases that's also true for
covid19 we also need a high enough rate
of people to get vaccinated in order to
protect people from getting coveted
again the vaccine's not 100 effective
it's very effective but not 100
and there are some people who can't get
vaccinated and those parents for example
want the people around their child to
get vaccinated and they rely on that
otherwise they wouldn't send their
children to school if it's a dangerous
environment we have that obligation to
protect everyone
uh representative fellows
thank you mr chair um
miss daly
i just wanted to make sure that i heard
you correctly did you say
that if we were to stop keeping records
of who was vaccinated for cobit then we
would be jeopardizing the availability
of those vaccines coming to us
that's correct under federal law and
in order for us to receive the vaccines
all health care providers are required
to document
the vaccination of individuals and share
that with their state health department
and cdc and so that is why there's an
executive order in place mandating the
submission of that data in our state
so thank you and a really quick
follow-up would that apply to any any
other vaccines do we get other vaccines
for free from the federal government or
i'm not i'm not sure with that yes we
thank you for that question we do get uh
vaccines for children we're a universal
state so we provide vaccines to all
would that be jeopardized also
no it would not that falls under state
law relative to our immunization
registry the providers do have to have
accountability for those publicly
purchased doses but it does not
necessarily have to be main name based
unless there's requirement by the state
which falls under immunization registry
law
representative allegro
thank you mr leo quick question to
clarify something i thought i heard
did you say that there are some people
who
cannot be vaccinated for
reasons of medical risk
that's correct
follow-up
should they be prevented from flying on
airplanes or riding buses or getting
jobs
so
in regards to immunization requirements
such as for schools which is really the
only thing the state requires regarding
immunizations there is a there is a
medical exemption so they can be
exempted for that purpose
should those be people be prevented from
riding on buses or in airplanes or from
getting jobs
there there is no requirement so i can't
speak factually too that's exactly what
but i'm here to speak to what has been
specifically put into writing which we
oppose
right
ask again please
should those people be prevented from
taking jobs or
taking an air flight or a bus ride thank
you
yeah believe the member is being
argumentative towards the witness he's
asked his question and she answered as
best she could
mr chairman my question wasn't answered
at all
and i find that highly entertaining um
that's okay i don't believe that that
falls within this witness's purview uh
our area of expertise
so we're gonna move along
uh representative schultz
i'm just curious um
maybe this is beating a dead horse
the conditions that would deem someone
unable to have the vaccine
is
can you describe
what those conditions are i imagine one
of them would be an allergy to
um
the other vehicles in the vaccine itself
i know egg can be one of those but what
are what are typically
the health conditions that make it
impossible for someone to get a vaccine
so medical exemption for vaccine is very
rare i believe in our childhood
population for school entry it's
point zero three or point zero four
percent of children get a medical
exemption
and it depends on the vaccine so for
coven 19 it's really focused around
allergies or having had a severe
reaction to a prior dose of coven 19
vaccine that's similar for other
vaccines however there might be some
children for example who have a very
rare you know immune deficiency and they
might not be the time for them to get
vaccinated until their immune system is
normal
yeah so they're probably not going on an
you probably can't answer that that's
okay
i mean none thank you for your testimony
doctor
thank you
put his hand up that should shoot
representative marsh if you're out there
okay
thank you mr chairman and members of the
very good
uh for the record i'm representative
william marsh carroll county eight
representing seven towns in southern
i'm speaking opposition to this
non-germain amendment and will refer to
line numbers in 1468 h and i will email
a copy of my testimony
amendment 1468-h is a non-german
amendment prohibiting discrimination
based on covet-19 vaccination status but
while this has a limited exception for
health care facilities the federal
statute 29 cfr 1630.2
are quoted on page 2 lines 12-22 does
not just apply to medical facilities it
applies to all employers
what about meat packing plants for
instance around the country numerous
people have contracted covid and some
have died in meat packing plants and
this has resulted in the closure of the
plants new hampshire actually has 12
meat packing plants according to
google maps is it not reasonable to want
employees to be vaccinated and or wear
mass to prevent a threat to our food
supply
and the language limiting vaccination
requirements on page 2 lines to 11 may
well directly conflict with 29 cfr
1910.1030
the osha bloodborne pathogen standard
which requires
all employers to offer hepatitis b
vaccination to unvaccinated employees
coming into contact with blood
page 1 lines 14 to 17 would make it an
unlawful discriminatory practice
discriminatory practice for any person
or government entity to deny an
individual access to goods services
employment housing education or places
of public accommodation based on an
individual's vaccination status or
immunity status
this last year we had the governor's
economic reopening task force on which
tim lang just soloway and i put in an
enormous number of hours representing
the new hampshire house
the task force always upheld the right
of any establishment to have stricter
rules than the state mandated if they
felt that necessary to protect their
employees or patrons
we felt each private business knew their
business better than we did
why would we interfere with their right
to protect themselves their employees
and their patrons in contrast this
amendment confers upon those who refuse
to take reasonable precautions the right
to go wherever they want and potentially
infect whomever they encounter this
language mirrors house bill 506 which
the health human services and elderly
affairs committee found inexpedient to
legislate on a 15 to 6 vote
section 12 starting on page 2 line 33 is
a rewrite of the immunization statute
incorporating changes hhs and elderly
affairs has rejected multiple times over
the years
adding measles to the list makes no
sense the two forms of measles are
already listed by their medical names of
rubella and rubiola
removing the commissioner's authority to
add diseases to the list rapidly by
rulemaking is senseless when our
children just missed a year of in-person
education due to a pandemic
given how connected our world is today
it is highly likely another virus will
emerge requiring a rapid response
five recent near misses should have made
us aware of the possibility of a
pandemic like covet
we had sars in 2003 h1n1 influenza in
mers in 2012
ebola in africa in 2014 and zika in
2015. in addition to these scientists
continue to monitor marburg virus la
hassa fever nipa virus crimean congo
hemorrhagic fever rift valley fever and
monkey pox the question is not whether
we will have another pandemic but when
will it happen
section 13 is a rewrite of house bill
health human services and elderly
affairs found that bill and expedient to
legislate on a 14-7 vote we heard
testimony that a similar measure in the
state of texas substantially raised the
cost of the vaccine registry the journal
of public health management practices
published in september 2010 reporting
that it raised the cost to the health
care system from 29 cents to 2.65 cents
per child
this amendment is unnecessary federal
law already prohibits mandating vaccines
unless there is a direct threat pursuant
to 29 cfr
1630.2r
the equal employment opportunity
commission has upheld this provision and
there's considerable case law about
employees being terminated for refusing
vaccinations we do not need to prohibit
a vaccine requirement in state law
because there is already such a
provision in federal law
last medically this amendment makes no
sense we all want to return to normal
where people can again have large group
gatherings a voluntary gathering of
people who share the knowledge that they
have been vaccinated allows this to
happen
if people don't want to get vaccinated
they don't need to participate but as a
state we need to move on from the social
distancing measures and their draconian
effect on the economy
vaccination allows us to do so safely
and so the public interest is to
encourage vaccination i urge the edna
committee to reject this amendment and i
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative marsh for taking my
question
did i hear you
correctly in your testimony that uh
number of uh portions of this bill
were brought in separate pieces of
legislation before the
um what i think is the appropriate
committee for this uh amendment the
health and human services and was itl
uh yes the most recent draft of this
bill that i have seen which is 1468 h
you may have seen a more recent one i do
not know uh section 12
is a rewrite of bills we've seen in the
past section 13 is a rewrite of house
bill 221 uh and uh page one lines
fourteen to seven which i think has been
in prior versions of this amendment uh
is a rewrite of house bill 506. uh all
those bills were found in expedia to
legislate uh by the hhs committee uh but
none had final action on the house floor
due to the expiration of deadlines so i
do not believe it would be a violation
of the house rules to bring this forward
however you are correct in your
assessment
thank you mr chairman
uh thank you dr marsh for your testimony
i'll use your
professional title instead of your
your elective title um because i respect
your medical expertise uh and your
testimony but my concern is with the
uh
situation
that currently exists in the world
uh that reminds me of what happened uh i
was not quite as old as i appear and
didn't ex experience it in my own
lifetime but the great pandemic of 1918
started out relatively benignly as i
understand it and
and developed through mutation
into a much more virulent form
and i'm very concerned about the
mutations that are already uh in
evidence and especially the situation in
india where the vaccine uh is inadequate
to the
uh to the threat uh in terms of
availability not efficacy uh and now you
have a population of a billion three
hundred million people for the vaccine
for the virus uh to uh to run wild in
does it concern you that the possibility
of much more virulent strains uh
being developed and subsequently being
transported to the united states
would could be a tremendous threat to
the people of new hampshire if we do not
vaccinate our population as effectively
as possible
uh yes thank you for that question uh
peter
you are correct that the vaccine
variants are are very much a threat to
the world's health and the world's
economy uh it is believed that the
indian variant will become the prevalent
strain in the united kingdom
i've heard that may very well happen
within a matter of days it has appeared
in the united states uh the previous
variant from united kingdom as i
understand at this point in time the
prevalent variant in the united states
and it has already been shown to be uh
more contagious and also affects younger
population groups such as the children
in the schools uh the indian variant is
supposed to be even more so that way so
it may become even more important uh to
control uh the the disease through
vaccination should that happen
it is quite true that the
vaccination does not prevent all
infections
it reduces the incidence of infection in
populations uh however that's also
that's been fairly well established
and and just by doing that we minimize
the spread of disease uh regarding the
influenza pandemic uh i was not alive at
that time either my grandfather however
was practicing medicine in the united
states army at the time and i remember
some of his stories before he died but
not well enough to relate them to people
quick follow-up approximately how many
people are believed to have died in the
great pandemic of 1918 worldwide
i don't have that information at my
fingertips but i believe google could
supply it quite easily it was a large
number
right i believe the current estimate is
55 million people
are believed to have perished at least
so
we've we've been lucky so far with colby
thank you for your testimony today
doctor
thank you
any further questions for representative
marsh
uh yes thank you pierce so to my friend
uh representative marsh here
uh you know you you've you said
something here that the prior three
um
physicians have also said you said that
you made the statement of encourage
people to get vaccinated
i'm i'm trying to as i'm reading through
this i'm trying to see where this where
this does the opposite where it does not
or discourages people from getting the
vaccine because i don't see that in the
light in the language of this
at all so
if i help me out here if i'm missing
this where anything in this
non-tremaine amendment here
discourages
um
or prevents anybody from being
having access to vaccines
the the only way it would prevent access
to vaccine is an indirect effect if we
did not report things appropriately to
the federal government and therefore
lost our access to the coveted vaccines
that we are currently being supplied
with by the federal government but i
agree with you there's no language in
the draft of this amendment that i've
seen that specifically would prohibit
any further questions
representative smith do you have another
question just not take a hand
i just wanted to point out that uh
fellow state rep
tim horrigan it's in the waiting room
but he did not
add representative to the beginning of
his name
okay i'll get to him in a minute thank
you
um
[Music]
representative
chrisman
representative chrisman you can unmute
thank you good afternoon
i'll try to make this quick um
i have some
things to say i'm thank you for having
me mr chair and members of the committee
i'm representative leah cushman from
where i also serve on the house health
human services and elderly affairs
committee with representative marsh
today i'm speaking in support of this
amendment to sb 155 the amendment is
necessary and is a bold step
that we need the legislature must take
to protect the rights of the residents
of new hampshire
there isn't much that could be
considered more personable personal and
inalienable inalienable excuse me than
your right to privacy over your health
information we have federal laws to
protect this privacy and an amendment in
our state constitution specifically to
protect this right
where the federal law
excuse me laws fall short and where our
constitution must be upheld
this legislation fills in the gaps in
ensuring this protection
um the committee has heard
already from me on this topic so i'm
going to keep the points on the bill
brief
and they are we need this because it
protects people from discrimination in
good services houses employment
education and places of public
accommodation based on vaccination or
immunity status
we need this because it prevents
government from requiring vaccination or
proof of immunity
we need it because it provides for
narrow circumstances where vaccines can
be required but with provisions for
certain exemptions we need this because
it takes away the power of the
commissioner of dhhs to add vaccines to
the school requirements and gives that
power to the most representative body of
the people where it rightfully belongs
we need this because it makes the
vaccine registry an opt-in registry as
it was intended and will stop the
practice of tricking people into having
their vaccination records including
records of declining vaccination entered
into a government database
on the point that there is no vaccine
mandate requiring proof of immunity is a
backdoor mandate we are seeing that
government doesn't want to dirty its
hands with requiring a mandate so
they're using their public officials to
push out a message that businesses
should do the dirty work and require
vaccines for people to participate
um dr raymond wallston he he claims that
vaccines prevent cancer in children i i
am interested in seeing
what cancers and where that data comes
from he's he's wrong and respectfully
about the school requirements for
vaccines because in new hampshire we
have exemptions and the private and
public schools have the same
requirements for exemptions under the
law so
regardless of where you send your kids
they're still subject to those
requirements and exemptions
i'm glad he brought up the anecdote of
the child dying of a vaccine preventable
illness but however you know no illness
is completely vaccine preventable as
every vaccine has a unique failure rate
and some are more effective than others
um it's hard to prove that an
unvaccinated person was responsible for
uh unvaccinated child
contracting that illness when vaccines
are not 100 effective
public schools are the only place we
have ever had uh requirements for
i'm sorry public and private schools and
children's day care so the only places
we've ever had school requirements in
new hampshire and we've always had
exemptions so no one's forced to
vaccinate their children and it's not
just medical exemptions we have
religious exemptions as well
vaccinated and unvaccinated children go
to school together and that medical
information of of who is vaccinated and
who's not is protected and private
um it is true that over four thousand
deaths have been reported to the vaccine
adverse event reporting system
associated with coving 19 vaccinations
you can check the varus data for
yourself it's open to the public and to
ignore this and pretend it's not
happening as dr daley did is dangerous
and harmful
what she said highlights the nature of
the problem with vaccine sciences touted
by public health officials
they're complicit in overstating the
benefits while downplaying the risks
medical exemption for vaccination is
rare because we have a negative feedback
loop where
regulatory agencies and
public health officials say that vaccine
injury doesn't happen there's no adverse
effects it's super rare one in a million
so doctors don't recognize it when a
patient tells them they've had a
reaction they they ignore it or tell
them that it's not from that and then
they don't report them to the vaccine
adverse um event reporting system
uh which feeds back into the idea that
there are none none happening i have
patients who have experienced this
and i am a registered nurse i don't know
if i mention that
to representative marsha's point that
the federal rules allow for vaccination
exemptions i'm i'm very familiar with
that most employers are not and they
believe they can require vaccinations
and they do and they get away with it
because it's expensive and time
consuming to sue for wrongful
termination the federal rule only
protects employees and only when they
have a religious objection or medical
condition that contradicts getting the
vaccine
so you know even
if you have a philosophical or a
knowledge or a values based or cultural
based reason
you should still not have to get a
vaccination in my opinion it should be
for any reason
uh
representative marsh is right about
including measles and that was probably
an overlooked by the sponsor when
writing the bill trying to ensure that
all the required school vaccinations
currently in place are in statute when
we take away that authority from the
dhhs commissioner as we should um to his
mention of the osha requirement uh dr
marsh
about um
offering hepatitis b vaccines offering a
vaccination is different than from
requiring it
it's important unfortunate that some
members of the health human services and
elderly affairs committee in the house
um have not internalized their training
in medical ethics those have had that
have had it but i didn't forget what i
learned in in nursing ethics and the or
the oath that i swore to uphold the code
of ethics that governs my nursing
practice
um and the first provision of that code
of ethics is for me to protect the
rights of my patients it's to protect
their dignity and that includes their
autonomy
um and their self-determination so we
can never force coerce
um we can't overly push anybody into
taking a medical treatment
um i the oath i took as a legislator is
to uphold the constitution of new
hampshire and all of this brings statute
in line with the constitution the proper
role of government is to protect the
rights of the people separating people
into different classes based on their
private health information is an
abomination that flies in the face
of all medical ethics
advancement
this committee must stand strong and not
be swayed by bureaucrat bureaucrats who
will testify in opposition to this bill
no matter what industry talking points
they they have the rights of individuals
are first and foremost please do the
right thing
i will not take questions thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative
i did want to answer one point she
raised
she asked for information about cancer
the adpd vaccine
thank you representative schulzel though
i think you were out of order
um
i understand that but he did not make
that distinction and that's why i was
questioning
what kind of data they were looking at
it sounded like it was broad childhood
cancer data
children are the ones who get the hpv
we're not going to uh engage in argument
with the witnesses please and everyone
please be reminded unless i recognize
you um no speaking all right it's going
to get contentious enough as it is sorry
i wasn't trying to be contentious just
okay uh representative
oregon will be next with some
promotions and also mr chairman uh
senator sherman has asked to be
recognized
dr
dr sherman needs to leave he tells me
and
we should hear him before we hear
representative horgan
you know something i totally agree with
you representation
[Music]
can you promote him for me please uh
he's on the way
thank
[Music]
senator you you are good to go
thank you uh members of the committee
can you hear me mr chair
we hear you thank you
okay for the record my name is uh
senator tom sherman
i represent district 24 i'm also a
physician in clinical practice
for
and so today i speak
in both roles and i i have to tell you
that uh i couldn't
it's remarkable to me
how much you've heard today that just is
not correct
and i'll stick with the science first of
all there are multiple vaccines
that protect against cancer in my world
in gastroenterology the hepatitis b
vaccine
is probably the most prominent
it prevents hepatocellular carcinoma
but hpv also present prevents both
oral i'm sorry ear nose and throat
cancer so
another fact that is not a fact that you
heard
is that antibodies if you have positive
antibodies you don't need a vaccine that
is false
if you have antibodies and have prior
exposure
it's unclear your level of protection
it is becoming clearer as studies are
being
completed
but the vaccines have shown
remarkable
persistent
protection across multiple variants
and
based on the immunology of uh of
exposure
an antibody to one
particular strain of the virus
with which you were infected does not
necessarily confer
uh immune immunity to other strains
and in the vaccines case that's why
we've been talking about whether or not
a booster is necessary to broaden the
coverage or to reinforce the coverage
i would point out that you have some
people who came in
by zoom from out of town
who do not have clinical experience a
pathologist does not see patients they
see slides and they do forensics
so
you are hearing from clinical
practitioners from dartmouth and from me
from new hampshire
who are
fully in support of our current statute
and i do not believe that this broad
brush
uh is going to be at all helpful in fact
it is likely going to harm the people of
new hampshire i'll repeat that this
amendment would harm the people of new
hampshire because what we understand
about vaccines
is that vaccines
represent based on the science not based
on several of the people who've been
talking today
based on the science they represent the
second most important
tool we have in public health the first
most important
occurred back in the 1800s which was the
development of public septic and
drinking water supply
the second most important was vaccine if
you look at its effectiveness whether
it's polio small packs smallpox
these vaccines have saved hundreds of
millions of lives across the world and
yet this
bill this amendment
would prohibit reduce and otherwise
decrease
uh our ability to follow the public
health and science on vaccination
and
really the last thing i would say is
that the way i think about vaccines
there are some that benefit just the
person getting the vaccine a great
example is tetanus you get a tetanus
vaccine if you can get one
if you don't have an adverse reaction
and you don't get tetanus
but the rest of the vaccines varicella
rubiola pertussis
these are ones that protect not just me
but they protect many other people and
i was in a hearing on the senate side
where a gentleman
testified he was a doctor he testified
he came from out of town i won't say
where
but his advice given to a community
resulted in the second largest measles
outbreak in the country
and he was removed from the board of
practice by the board of medicine from
practicing in a state in
in the united states
i think it's really important to know
who's giving the testimony
and when i look across the board at our
doctor from dartmouth or dr marsh
or my own testimony you're talking
people from new hampshire
love new hampshire
and
love the people of new hampshire are
dedicated both in the legislature and
also in our practice of madison
and our number one thing in our
hippocratic oath is do no harm and we
fully support the public health tools
that are needed to provide vaccination
to as many people as can and will
and there is nothing in there that says
that an adult who does not want a
thank you thank you and i'll take any
questions you might have
uh representative
senator thank you for taking that
question you you are wearing two hacks
today and uh so i'll ask one to your
other side uh not the physician side and
do you think that people should be
um i think the key word there is force i
am not i am not in favor of vaccine
passports
i am not in favor of vaccine mandates
except
where they
affect the public health which is what
we currently have which are children who
are going into a
public system like the public schools
and i also don't believe it's the role
of the legislature to tell businesses
what they can and can't do
if a business feels that
they want their employees to be
vaccinated
that's up to the business
is it um follow-up question please um
i've heard this um point made several
times about us
in the legislature
stepping outside of our role telling
businesses what they should and
shouldn't do
i
find this interesting because in the
legislature here in new hampshire and
across the country that's what we do on
so uh
again i'm not sure i
got the answer to my question should
the legislature
be allowing other citizens to force
other citizens to be vaccinated
and again
well again i will i will ask you know as
a condition of employment is that
coercing or forcing
you know
that that's part of the definition i
don't believe
if an adult makes a sound a sound mind
and body makes a choice
uh
you know to not get a vaccine there are
likely going to be consequences
that come along with that
does that mean that i'm forcing them to
get a vaccine absolutely not i'm not
coercing them i'm not forcing them i'm
saying that's your choice
and as a private business owner i also
have a choice
and
you know
it's it's unusual to hear you
saying that you want to write regulate
private businesses but that's what i'm
hearing
or regulate them more i'm surprised at
that but
that's what you're telling me
[Music]
no actually i'm i'm not
saying that but that's neither here nor
there it's not so important what i say
um
coercion
force
whatever the word be
is it not forcing someone
if you tell them you'll be vaccinated or
you can't have this job or
you can't ride this bus or
is that not coercion thank you and
that'll follow up no i'll answer that
i'll say no that's not coercion
coercion is if i said
uh
you cannot walk down a road without a
vaccine and say you cannot leave your
house
without a vaccine
that is something where you know we had
a stay-at-home order and i know some
people disagreed with that
that is a public health measure
but if you have available vaccine and a
private business says to you
you know
i choose as a business owner not to have
people working here putting in my other
employees at risk
then
you can choose as a potential employee
whether or not to participate in that
business you have that choice that
doesn't fit under any definition of
coercion or forced employment in my
understanding of the dictionary
thank you for that clarification
representative
senator sherman is as serious as all
this is i've got to ask you 35 years
where's your fountain of youth
yeah i started well i went to med school
let's see i graduated in 1987.
so i've been in clinical medicine since
then
representative judy
yes thank you mr chair uh senator
uh i received so many emails
from
my constituents in one three
one of them uh
could
i think the long-term effects
of this
vaccine may be very destructive
to our natural broad-based human system
uh i would like to know uh if
this constitute is uh is what he's
saying is true or not please
so
let me make sure i've got the question
correct
are you asking whether i believe there
is long-term destruction to the immune
system from
because the the amendment is all
vaccines so
although the title says covet the
okay
so so i'm just trying to clarify
are you asking about the covet vaccine
or all vaccines
especially
i know of
no
evidence
that
a a long-term
immune destruction or impact on the
immune system other than
protection against getting
coveted
is a side effect of the vaccine
what i would say though is that people
have quoted the number of deaths from
the vaccine and i think that has to be
taken in the context of the
more than 100 million people who have
you know 4 000 or 2 000 deaths that's
any death is one too many
but when you look at covid in any age
group
it has a much higher mortality than that
[Music]
this is my question
um
what do you think
if someone take the cove vaccine shots
and then
that will protect that person from
does it protect them from variants
is that what you're asking
yes well you know that we haven't
studied
or all of the variants have not been
studied because variants keep emerging
but it's very encouraging that at least
the pfizer
and the moderna vaccines
do offer fairly broad immunity
uh not a hundred percent by any stretch
but as uh earlier stated no vaccine
offers a hundred percent immunity
but
it does offer broad immunity against
most of the variants that are out there
i don't believe
we know yet about india
but the beauty of this process
is that you can take the variants that
are known say in the fall
they develop a
a booster that would address the new
variants
then you don't need to go through the
two vaccine series that you went through
for modern or pfizer you would get
updated with a booster like you do for
tetanus
but it would
be a booster that would not only
reinforce what you've already
gained immunity to but also be able to
yeah i was trying to find the button
thank you
um dr sherman is it not true that um
with most viruses particularly
the coveted strains
that we can expect to see variants
coming forward
um
that's
so your question is are we anticipating
more variants in the future
from what it's my understanding that
it's the nature of viruses too
yes it is kind of a path around
preventions
well it yeah it actually is and some of
the more wily viruses like hepatitis c
for example we don't have a vaccine to
it because it changes
so quickly that we can't develop a
vaccine that would
reach a persistent marker on the virus
so that we don't have a vaccine
fortunately we have treatment
um
albeit very expensive treatment um
the
uh you know the the options we have for
dealing with
um
covid for the future since it will
continue to mutate like viruses do
our number one we could continue
to
be uh to practice the same level of
social distancing and masking and all
the other
uh
precautions that we have put in place
until we develop the virus the vaccine
or we could continue to
um move the vaccine as robustly as
people will allow so that
we get ahead of the variance so that we
provide
a level of immunity and you know what
they have seen which is which is true of
many vaccines is that there is some
degree of what's called cross reactivity
in other words the vaccine will actually
help even if it's a variant and that's
what they're seeing
the original vaccines were designed for
a certain
type of of
covid
but we're finding that they are actually
effective across many of the different
variants and
so not only will vaccines decrease the
spread of covid through our population
but they also
provide a certain amount of protection
um
against the variants even ones that they
thank you
uh thank you senator
you bet thank you
[Music]
next i will call uh representative leon
you had your hand raised
um yes thank you very much mr chair for
taking my question and committee members
for hearing such uh
thorough discussions from from from
everyone for the record i am erica leon
state representative from derry and a
former wall street medical device
analyst
i speak to you today as somebody who
worked in drug and device development
who was highly involved in the fda
approval process
who has studied a lot of medical ethics
and has also been involved in the
learning process after the sars pandemic
and how
the knowledge there could have been was
used in order to streamline the vaccine
development process and make sure that
something gets out to people
my first point is that despite best
efforts this is a long process there are
a lot of necessary stops along the way
as you find
a vaccine candidate as you develop it
and as you grow it along the process in
order to make sure that it's not going
to hurt people and hopefully it will
help
when we had the best minds from industry
they they saw it as a pipe dream to get
something based off of standard
technology out the door in nine months
and we've seen practically a miracle
with the availability of this coveted
vaccine
it's clear that there is a lot of
interest in it and if we look at the
fact that a third of americans are
already vaccinated without any coercion
or force it shows that education is
working
here in new hampshire we have one of the
highest seat belt
rates in the country
yet we don't mandate seat belts for
adults
we trust that people here can look at
the information make wise decisions and
not be forced to act in a way that
protects themselves and others
what we're debating here is whether or
not businesses can be used to implement
public health policy
if we can if we allow businesses
to require proof of vaccination or
immunity to
conduct business or go into a facility
this is a huge leap
this is a problem if we are asking or
allowing businesses to be an enforcement
arm for public health
there is informed consent
there is informed consent that is
required for anybody to take or
participate in the clinical trial and
while we have a large amount of
information that suggests that this
vaccine is beneficial we don't have
enough to force its use among the
population we can't force people to make
that choice
and if you look to other states we have
california where they're opening up and
they're allowing people into the
amusement parks but if you're from out
of state you need to prove your status
this is the sort of thing that moves
across the country obviously we're not
going to do that as government
but we also need to make sure that there
is no discrimination based upon vaccine
status
we worked incredibly hard in the 80s to
make sure that there was not
discrimination based upon a far more
fatal disease hiv
we've worked on many other issues that
do have public health implications to
make sure that there is not
discrimination on that basis
i'm confident that with information
many people will make a choice to get
take the coven 19 vaccine
but coercing people is going to dig in a
lot of heels and make some people who
otherwise might get the vaccine
say no you're not going to force me to
do this
and we need to not lie to ourselves if
we allow businesses to do this we are
allowing this back doorway to force
people to be vaccinated
and that is unacceptable
thank you
any questions representative
thank you mr chair representative leon
how is it forcing someone
to take vaccine if an employer
just says this condition of employment
but you can choose to be employed
someplace that does not force you to do
that
thank you for the question
representative
do we allow employers to fire people for
other personal decisions say as to
say as to um
there's a lot of other choices that you
have you know you can say whether or not
who you love is a person is a choice
but to just openly discuss your status
is is a choice that some people make i
have family members who have been very
quiet about that are we allowed to
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative um for your testimony
very thoughtful um
my question to you is uh i have received
lots of lots of emails with this uh
amendment
um and i've tried to read each one of
them even if they're saying the same
thing over and over again in many cases
uh i still look to see who they are and
where they're from and what their issues
are
and one of the things that uh is coming
up pretty frequently is the idea of
of the idea of uh not wanting to create
a two-tiered system
um and you're you've kind of been
cutting at that the edge of that
in your testimony as well
but the the amendment
uh restricts
all the
business entities that
uh that do business with the state in
virtually any way
and would deny them uh their
continuation of their contracts and so
forth i don't know whether you've gotten
any of these
emails or not
but
if we
if we prohibit all the businesses that
do business with the state
uh from
doing anything along the lines of
requiring
vaccination or
coercing vaccination or or suggesting
vaccination phrased in different ways
if if if we prohibit that group of thing
and we don't prohibit all businesses
from doing it
uh aren't we creating a two-tier system
thank you representative for the
thoughtful question um
this is the question of the carrot or
the stick if we are using this if we're
allowing business some businesses to use
the stick to say that without proof of
vaccine you may not do business with us
that
that absolutely is a problem and i i
think that this should apply to all
businesses because just because
hannaford market basket and chaws don't
receive government i'm not sure if they
receive government funding but i don't
think they do just because they don't
may not receive it doesn't mean that if
they all decide
that they want to require proof of
vaccination in order to shop
i
will be left going to other places like
growing my own garden raising my own
food or going to co-ops
denial of access to a whole class of
industries say if all of the grocery
stores
require proof of vaccination that would
be an undue hardship and that would go
even further than jim crow laws did in
the south
schmidt just for a point of
clarification the current uh iteration
of the amendment actually prohibits all
business not just businesses that do
aha that's the newest version is this a
public hearing on that amendment as well
mr chairman it doesn't seem like it is
yes
[Music]
and it was circulated thank you
representative
thank you
um
okay
dr coalish
[Music]
um
yes hi this is dr donald collis can you
thank you very much mr chairman and
members of the committee for permitting
my testimony um
i've been a new hampshire doctor for now
for more than 40 years and if i count as
uh dr sherman did from the time i
graduated medical school um
it'll be
25 44 years i think
um
and with apologies i came in quite late
i was tied up at a meeting so i missed
all of the arguments um until just most
recently
um and so i'm speaking just based on my
reading of of the amendment
and if i'm reading this correctly mr
chairman
this
amendment
um would establish a very broad
prohibition
um against keeping records
about against
initiating conversations
um
about vaccination status
this seems to me although i'm i'm a
practicing doctor i used to practice up
in the north country in a north country
conservative community which highly
values personal liberty i now currently
am working at the va
i'm not a bureaucrat i'm a practicing
doctor and teacher this seems to me
so overly broad as to be extremely
dangerous
when i practice in that conservative
north country community
my patients expected me to care for them
they expected me to be a professional
which means that i would consider their
health to be more important than my own
personal political beliefs
they expected me to advocate for their
there's clearly established
appropriateness
for schools to require vaccinations
there's clearly established
law and statute that permits businesses
and other institutions
to protect their employees and their
customers
this amendment as i read it and again
with apologies um
mr chair i'm
i'm not a a lawyer or a legislator but
it seems to me that this amendment is so
broadly prohibitive
um of behaviors that will
um that would let
institutions protect their
clients their students their customers
and their employees as to be extremely
dangerous
and if i take seriously my role as an
advocate for the health of my patients
and my community i see this as being
very dangerous
thank you very much mr chairman and
committee members
thank you for your testimony any
questions
doctor
sharer's going to now
hello this is repton horrigan so i
represent i'm uh
i guess you can actually see me too
there i'm representing timothy horrigan
i'm from trafford county district six
thanks for calling on me um traffic
county just exists in the towns of
durham and madbury
durham is not coincidentally the home of
unh some which
had
a very extensive uh testing program
which was far ahead of what was being
done in the rest of the state in fact
there's pretty much no program at all
early in the pantheon income and they
are also ahead of the curve for
vaccinations even though there's a
little bit of hiccup when
the
governor decided that they should only
be vaccinating students
who were residents of new hampshire
although
technically they're all residents of new
hampshire because they're all they've
all been here
all these months so anyway
um this certainly um could have been an
especially huge catastrophe in my town
with all the uh young people living in
close quarters and they did a lot of
things um including having a remote
classes to ameliorate that but um
and it would have been serious even for
uh for for young people uh it has killed
some young people and even people who
survived have uh
sometimes very unsettling and uh
you know life
you know life-altering symptoms like for
example my uh my nephew who
he goes to school bu not a unh but still
uh you know he still hasn't regained his
sense of taste and smell and um you know
he's a
bit of a foodie so that has been
extremely distressing to him so like
just the uh
um
even just saying it's got a 99 survival
rate that's still like one out of 100.
so i think you know the consequences are
aside from death death is not the only
bad consequence of this that's a very
very serious disease um it's
killed just the united states
600 000 uh people which makes it the
worst catastrophe since the civil war so
it's definitely not a hoax it's
definitely um hasn't been exaggerated i
guess there's people who think even the
civil war was a hoax but that's a
besides the point so it's
really one of the worst things that ever
happened in asia's history so it was
even worse than um what we've seen in
the media and so and the vaccines
i'm not going to say they're i'm not
going to say they're they're perfect but
they've been effective and um you know
it's kind of a
like uh i guess what representative
cushman mentioned the uh
aids epidemic i was living in new york
city when the aids epidemic started that
was for the episode united states it was
uh not as deadly as kobe it was it was
horrible but uh you know covet is
you know a magnitude of or worse than
anything else we've ever seen and
certainly is um
uh
certainly there's no
constitution maybe it may be con there's
no constitutional right or human right
to affect others you know so there's uh
when you have
an infectious disease as serious as cova
that's just like um you know if you have
uh
you don't have the right to infect
somebody with ebola you know you don't
write somebody with with hiv even though
it wasn't um
that was not nearly as contagious as
coving so that's the idea
that somehow there's a constitutional
right to infect others is i think a
fallacious argument and i'm usually an
extremist when it comes to it
it comes to liberty and also we already
uh
we already have a large number of other
health requirements for schools and jobs
um you know like uh most many jobs you
have to get drug tested um i've had i
was a uh
i worked in a
i worked in public transportation while
i had to be uh i myself had to be drug
tests and i didn't like it but you know
it was not a violation of my human
rights so it's not
illegal um you have to have tb tests for
many jobs you have to have your child
vaccinated against very various
childhood diseases
during the children so this is um
basically the same principle
the same principle that for for decades
has uh
has required those types of vaccinations
and those types of tests um those type
of precautions and also apply here in my
opinion and
once again i'll repeat
this is one of the worst catastrophes in
our nation's history perhaps in world
history and uh by the way
um i was just in a meeting about vital
records a few days ago and
this was a 12-month period just ended i
believe it was the first time that
they've ever recorded that more people
died in new hampshire than were born and
that's uh
true in lots of other places and true
nationwide and so that's including both
the deaths that were coded being
directed in covid
as well as a
death from from from other causes and
certainly it's
just
infinitely more serious than many things
that were much more worked up into this
legislature it's more dangerous for
example than
rear-facing car seats for example so
that's uh
i think
you know it's i think
businesses uh and even government i mean
i don't like everything the government
does but um
it's necessary and frankly i've been a
legislator for 13 years
i'm part of the government it's not
something entirely separate from me you
know it's uh
you know this is a
it's pandemic is it's only been around
we've only known about it's only been
around for like a little over a year
it's we there's a lot we don't know
about it but one thing we do know is
that uh
first of all preventative measures such
as uh
such as mass and so forth work we also
know there isn't really
that much in the way of effective
treatments if you do catch it and also
but the vaccines uh yes they're
developed basically this is still
experimental they actually
[Music]
today
frozen
from our committee hey what's up steve
good to see you all again the record my
name's steve bowden i reside in
rochester new hampshire
and i'm here today to speak in support
of amendment number 11 1443 h back on
december i mean i'm sorry april 21st the
hearing on amendment number 11 40
49 in today's testimony much of it has
centered around the dangers and the
efficacy of the vaccine
neither this amendment or amendment 1149
addresses that instead they deal with
employee employer demands that their
employees or that those attending public
events receive a vaccine
the intent of this amendment is to
protect liberty and a person's right to
choose without this legislation
businesses will be free to exercise
authority over people's personal health
decisions there may be some reluctance
on the part of legislators to interfere
with private business decisions but we
already do that many ways age sex gender
identity race creed color marital status
physical or mental disability or natural
origin of any person
are already protected by government why
then should the choice of what a person
puts in their body be protected as well
our constitutions both federal and state
address our right of privacy to move
about freely beyond that hipaa laws
provide additional privacy rights
and ada protects us from discrimination
based on medical conditions
without the protections afforded by this
amendment a person's only recourse their
employer mandates that they take this
experimental drug is to file suit
against their employer should protection
from discrimination only be available to
people that can afford legal counsel i'd
like to add that
if someone were to ask about someone's
uh hiv status or whether or not they
have hepatitis they would be violating
the law if an employer did that
this vaccination has only received
emergency eu thought use authorization
by the fda as such it is considered an
experimental drug
the nuremberg code and this was
mentioned previously of permissible
medical experiments prohibits compelled
use of experimental drug the code in
part states that you should be voluntary
should be based on successful animal
experimentation and should be conducted
only by scientifically qualified persons
especially when there are alternative
treatments available which in this case
there are many
given these facts people should be able
to freely choose or not to take any
vaccination that does not have a proven
safety record and has not been
thoroughly tested and this bill
requires that any vaccination that's
mandated be thoroughly tested
what about people that have had covered
and have developed a natural immunity
and i think the two doctors that spoke
at the beginning of today's testimony
have addressed that are we going to
unnecessarily and wastefully force them
to take the vaccine what harm could come
about from taking a vaccination when
you've already got an immunity we don't
know that
don't let the testimony of the 21st
distract you from what's at issue here
and that is the compelled use of a drug
possibly unnecessarily through the
threat of unemployment and denial of a
person's freedom to participate in
society and to that point if i spent 30
or 40 years in my career and then
suddenly my employer comes to me and
says you have to take this vaccine or
you're going to be terminated am i to
give up my lifelong career because my
employer demanded it of me i don't think
that would be right
we've heard a lot of talk about
so-called vaccine passports the biden
administration has been clear will not
mandate vaccine passports but what is
the difference between a government
mandate and a private sector mandate in
either case your rights have infringed
if people's rights are violated it's
irrelevant if they are violated by
government or industry the fact remains
they were violated
and i'd like to point out uh something
that uh others have said and that is
that um
that they they have said in their words
that
they don't support
vaccine passports but if you read
between the lines it's clear that they
do
in order to safeguard people's rights of
privacy employment and the right to
choose i urge the committee to support
passage of senate bill 155 with
amendment number 1443-h thank you
there being none it was good to see you
again thank you for your testimony
likewise thank you
uh at this point i'm going to call on
thank you very much for uh letting me
testify i'll do my best to be concise so
i wrote it down
um
i
i am fully in support of this amendment
because we need protection from
discrimination against people who either
know they cannot take vaccines
or they think they are at risk for
complications
there have been scores of double-blind
placebo
in international clinical trials on
thousands of people that prove the
efficacy of old proven well-tested safe
medication combinations
that have treated covet 19 successfully
but you probably have never heard of
them unless you look them up because for
some reason the news media is not
interested in them and when they post on
things like facebook
they're taken down and called
disinformation
despite
piles
of of our mountains as they say of data
and the nih finally decided that they
could look at it in january they issued
um a neutral position where as they said
before they were against it now they put
it equal to um
the same uh let's see the
um
shoot and
it escapes me it's what they gave
president
uh
president trump that healed him
uh i think the real issue here
is the public health benefits that we're
assuming that we're trying to protect
everyone the best we can
so number one
vaccinated people shouldn't have to be
worried about being exposed to
unvaccinated people
it's that simple
if the taking a vaccine protects you
then why are you demanding not you but
the people who say oh everybody needs to
take it that doesn't make sense because
if the vaccine protects you then by
golly you should be protected and it
shouldn't matter who you're exposed to
and then the other people that you
that i do hear people concerned about
are the ones i just mentioned people who
cannot take a vaccine because they know
that it's dangerous for them
well it's not just covet they are at
risk from
if they can't if they if they're if they
are immunodeficient
there are lots of things that are
dangerous to them so just everybody
taking a covered vaccine does not mean
that they can go out in public and be
exposed to everybody
um
the statistical uh evaluation
shows that people most at risk for covid
are not only elderly
and plenty of us fit in there
but we
we don't have comorbidities the people
who are at risk are elderly and have
comorbidities
the
other people who are serious at risk are
obese
and i just read something that explains
one of the factors that contributes to
that
vitamin d deficiency the research has
shown that vitamin d deficiency relates
correlates highly with uh susceptibility
to covid
and the more fat somebody sells somebody
has the d that they have taken in is
diluted throughout their body so the
more the more fat cells you need more d
to get the level up in your bloodstream
that's where it fights the disease and
some doctors are really good now about
testing serum d3 levels but others have
we have doctors we need to remind but
they used to say 30 nanograms per
milliliter was high normal
what they found now
a hundred is high normal and the people
who measure 65 and above
not only have a much
either they don't get coveted at all or
they get very mild cases
and as a side benefit the incidence of
breast cancer is reduced by 87
so that's something you know that would
be wonderful to hear more research i
wish the government would pay for that
because d3 is super cheap and extremely
difficult to get in our in our
diet
you take those little pills fortunately
they're pretty small
and they're inexpensive and available
um
the clinical trials
that unfortunately are being
i already said that they've already been
suppressed so you really have to look at
them two of the organizations that have
real good data are the flccc which is
frontline coving critical care they have
done
enormous numbers of clinical trials one
of the most impressive was the one in
in south america
where they tested
they gave
12 1200 health care workers were
involved
and 400 of them
got the placebo
and 800 of them
got the ivermectin combined with another
another drug the results were astounding
of the 400 people who got the uh the
placebo
58 of them tested positive or got sick
of the 800 who got the preventive
nobody got sick
that's pretty impressive
so the old fear that if you don't take a
vaccine you have no treatment you're at
risk for death is wrong
all you have to do is look for it
and go down your pharmacy that's what
i'm doing i'm taking the vitamin d but
i'm taking a whole lot of the vitamins
that are recommended by the flccc
so again i think oh that bears data
somebody questioned
the vares data i'm sorry my
my internet apparently was playing
little little games uh the vares which
stands for vaccine adverse event
reporting system which has been around
for a long time but a lot of times
people don't report that they have a
vaccine response or they the doctors
just say of course that's normal but the
doctors have to report deaths so the
number of deaths in which the cdc says
they think they're under reported
it's well over 4 000 people have died
and even if that's a low percentage
compared to the millions of people who
have taken the vaccines
if it happens to you or your family
it's a hundred percent
so please protect protect me from
discrimination do not do not keep me
from being able to travel or to go and
stay at a restaurant go to a restaurant
or stay in a hotel
i'm protecting myself and if you've had
your vaccine you really should not be at
risk so please please support this
amendment thank you thank you
um
mr russ payne one more time
okay
john schmidt i'll be promoting you
must
can you hear me
i fully support this amendment
it'll protect my rights
i want i've heard a lot of science today
so forgive me i want to bring up one
more little tiny piece of science that i
think everybody should hear
and that's the germ theory of disease
versus the terrain theory of disease
the germ theory of disease is what all
these vaccines are based on and it has
never been proven never not even for one
disease
it is it is nonsense
the terrain theory of disease is the
correct theory of disease and that says
that disease is caused by a buildup of
toxins in the body and or a lack of
nutrition
nutrition also helps you to remove
toxins from the body things like vitamin
c
i also heard some discussion today about
some diseases so let me tell you the
truth about them spanish flu
was not caused by any infectious agent
no virus no bacteria caused the spanish
flu
doctors used hundreds of volunteers back
then and tried to infect them
with material from from cadavers who had
died from the spanish flu they were
unable to get anybody sick
they also had sick animals like horses
that died they tried to infect healthy
horses they could not
so yeah a lot of people died from the
spanish flu but it was not caused by any
infectious agent so down goes with the
germ theory there
one of the things that killed people
during the spanish flu was the vaccines
they had for it and also an extreme
overdose of aspirin a lot of people were
bleeding to death we now know that
aspirin causes bleeding
so that was the spanish flu polio is
another nonsense uh virus
polio is actually caused by ddt
uh
this fear of uh
these mosquitoes caused ddt being
sprayed all over the place and some
people could detox it some could not
those who could not got nerve damage and
they got paralysis
and that was polio and they called that
from a virus that was nonsense
uh aids is another fake virus the
inventor
of carrie mullis the inventor of the pcr
test and by the way carrie mueller said
you can't use his pcr test to diagnose
any disease
well they're using it to diagnose
diagnose covid
that's how they they've created this
what i call scandemic with all these
cases cases mostly of healthy people
could you possibly
limit your testimony to the bill and not
to actual
theories on science on past viruses
please
well okay but everybody else was talking
science so i figured i could i could
bring up some of these things to tell
the truth about the other things that
people were talking about that other
people mentioned polio and
spanish flu etc as far as the bill is
concerned
i don't believe in the in the germ
theory of disease i will not take any
vaccine i don't belong to that church of
uh
vaccineology i don't want to be forced
to join that church
and i hope you people will protect my
rights i moved to new hampshire in 2012
because it was the free estate on the
east coast
and i hope i don't have to move out of
new hampshire but if i can't travel and
i can't shop and i can't live a normal
life then i'm going to have to go to
florida or texas or somewhere
protected thank you
anyone else wishing to testify um please
raise your hand i know some people have
signed up but they're no longer with us
in the room so
it would be helpful if you raise your
hand so we're going to go with
my c representative morgan you've
dr jj smith
[Music]
dr smith you can unmute
justify
okay great so thank you
um thank you representatives for hearing
my testimony um i'm dr j.j smith i am a
retired family practitioner i also have
a public health degree and i represent
the public health association of new
hampshire
and um i mostly want to just echo a lot
of things that were said by dr sherman
dr marsh
and um
yes i'm name blocking at the moment um
the head of the bureau of infectious
disease
um the they're all entirely correct but
i wanted to just emphasize some things
number one um
we are talking about
this amendment not the one that you
heard three weeks ago that was specific
to code but and this is a really um
terrible
idea to try to say that all vaccines
can be um
a source of
someone discriminated against
another person for failing to get
vaccine it's well
well established in law including
supreme court decision
that infectious diseases there can be
requirements
and
i think this whole issue around
employment is an extremely important one
to talk about
this amendment states that
it would have to be a direct threat well
how do you assess a direct threat of
aerosol transmitted disease which has
asymptomatic spread that is people who
have not
got symptoms are spreading it and that's
true of covid which isn't even mentioned
in this amendment
it's true of a number of other diseases
and things that we are very thankful we
have good vaccines for
and
i have in my own experience seeing
a
baby with german measles terribly
afflicted
that's just really unnecessary and if
you say an employer
can't require
that
a child care place or any place that a
pregnant woman might
end up
can't require that i mean
that that's ridiculous so
we we did in fact at the time i was
going through training require anyone
who worked in our hospitals
to have german measles vaccine or
immunity proven
by
um blood tests
so that's the kind of thing we need and
it's also
we found out about 40 years ago after a
debacle from bad science where someone
invented their data
and got a whole lot of people to stop
immunizing their children against
whooping cough that whooping cough
actually is transmitted regularly among
adults it just doesn't look like
whooping cough it looks like any
ordinary bronchitis
and so it gets reintroduced immediately
into pediatric populations some of the
children would die
so
you know this is not an easy thing and i
i also wanted to just
quickly state that there is a
misunderstanding about the vares system
the vaccine advance adverse event
reporting system
you are reporting stuff that has not
been proven to be
from the vaccine and a lot of
coincidental things are happening
after people receive vaccine
and unless you have done a placebo
control you don't know
and actually placebo-controlled trials
on the influenza vaccine have been done
and shown that all of these people who
say oh influenza vaccine gives me
influenza i can't take it are incorrect
because the rate of adverse events from
influenza vaccine is identical to a
saline injection salt water injection
except for sore arm
and the sore arm is expected
so
there's nothing about the vares reports
of 4000 deaths after covid19 vaccine
that indicates the copenhagen vaccine
has killed anyone we do know that the
astrazeneca and the j j vaccine have
triggered some immune thrombocytopenic
um
bleeding
and it's really that's terrible but it's
extraordinarily rare and the vaccines
that have mostly been used in this
country the pfizer and the moderna have
not triggered any such things and
there's only rare immune reactions and
most of them have been successfully
treated
um
so
i i think all in all this this bill
number one doesn't address covert
directly and it would have all kinds of
negative effects that dr
daly spoke to you about
and i would just also reiterate that
vaccines are not a hundred percent
so that if we allow
that we don't want people to be
forced to vaccinate to
work in certain places they will infect
other people
if they
get the disease and pass it on whether
they're symptomatic or not which is
definitely the case with a number of
diseases including covet 19
and those other people might have had
their vaccines and they might be very
susceptible and yes there are treatments
that help but they don't 100 percent
prevent death
or serious illness
so i think we're making great progress
it correlates well with the vaccine to
uh
put a a quite
definite
you're listening to fake science when
people tell you the vaccine doesn't work
um the
drop in infections here has been largely
correlated with the extension of vaccine
and we don't have anywhere near enough
natural infection to think that's the
reason and i would also point out that
there have been no reports
yet
that getting the vaccine after having
had natural infection causes problems
and we don't really expect there will be
and in point of fact there is some
evidence
that you will have improved immunity
against reinfection if you get
vaccinated despite having had covert 19
before
i think i've talked enough if you have
any questions i'd be happy to answer
them
thank you very much
mr chairman uh dr uh i wonder whether
you could address the question that i
asked of
um
of
dr sherman i believe with regard to the
uh
maybe with dr marsh with regard to the
development of mutations that are
already
demonstrated to be rapidly spreading
uh and to have some significant
differences in characteristics in terms
of contagiousness
and also lethality uh and with the
population of india being a billion 300
million people and the disease is
running wild there uh
are you fearful of the implications of a
of a more
dangerous
uh variant
rapidly spreading in the united states
if we don't have enough people
vaccinated
um yeah i think that's a legitimate
concern i don't think we know i mean
yes
all viruses mutate some more readily
than others and sometimes that allows
them to escape immune surveillance but
it doesn't always
and
in point of fact it may well be that we
already have the most infectious one
that we're going to have we have the uk
variant now predominantly and the uk
variant is more infectious it does not
seem to be causing more
severe illness
it does in fact
have good coverage by both of our
well even by the jnj vaccine but pfizer
and modern are definitely have good
coverage for that now will something
come back into our population that we
have less good coverage or dr sherman
did address that
and i think he's correct that it could
happen and we may end up needing a
booster if that happens but i don't
think that's something where we
necessarily will see that happen the
south africa variant um unfortunately
the astrazeneca which they were using
widely um was not actually effective
enough um so that became a real problem
will something become that bad here it
could i hope not i i'm pretty old myself
um so you know i've been pretty locked
down for most of a year plus and
now that i'm vaccinated i'm
enjoying life a little more now thank
you
follow-up question mr chairman uh what
about the long-haul phenomenon that is
uh that we're learning more about people
who are losing their sense of taste and
smell as an example
and
they say if you don't get it back
relatively quickly
you probably won't get your taste to
smell back a taste and smell back and
that would be a terrible thing for a
person to go through their lives and
dangerous as well with no sense of taste
or smell
i i think there are other other long
hauler phenomena as well i think those
are serious issues and and you know i
think there are other long-haul kinds of
things that some people are developing
chronic fatigue type symptoms um which
may or may not be due to some other
viruses we've never recognized maybe a
covet virus that we i mean another
coronavirus a covet um
and
it's just it's something that would be
wonderful to prevent and
you know maybe more people wearing masks
all winter
when more respiratory viruses are spread
because we're confined indoors with each
other might be a good thing in the long
run so we might have learned something
great about reducing the spread of
things that
we didn't even know were causing such
serious problems for a small percentage
of people
so thank you thank you doctor thank you
okay can you hear me chairman
yes
wonderful thank you for taking my
testimony my name is linda ray camarota
from bedford new hampshire
i'm a registered nurse i have children
that have been vaccinated
um
i want i'm responding to amendment 1468
h
and i just want to
put in a couple of comments with regard
to what i've heard this afternoon
um
one of the reps wanted to know what it
might cost to have antibody tests done i
happen to have one done and it was ten
dollars cost me ten dollars out of
pocket
childhood
vaccinations
are mandated in the state of new
hampshire
because they have been fda approved
what we're talking about today what i'm
talking about today is as it relates to
the
coronavirus
vaccine it should be understood that
it's experimental
and because it's experimental
it is one of my strongest positions that
it should not be mandated if it got to
the point where the fda did what it
normally does when it's not under
emergency authorization use
then
you know we couldn't come back to the
drawing table
somebody also said that
one of the doctors that testified
earlier was
not um really his credentials were not
up to speed but he did state he's an
immunologist so i put value into his
testimony
and last i haven't read my testimony but
on page two of
the amendment
section
clearly states that all parents and
legal guardians shall
have their children who are residing in
the state immunized against certain
diseases so i don't see anything in here
that
creates
a dangerous situation
for our children
so testimony come before you today in
full support of this amendment
the past 14 months have turned our
worlds upside down and we now have the
opportunity to reflect on the actions
taken in attempt to mitigate the impact
of the pandemic many actions resulted in
positive outcomes here in new hampshire
and some will have unintended
consequences it's much too early to
see what the future holds for us the
learning curve has been significant and
now we're here to rebalance our families
communities and the state i want to
address three areas of utmost concern as
it relates to this amendment
one is we heard a little bit about human
rights and discrimination
and as it relates to the experimental
nature of this injection
um no emergency authorized medical
product i'm talking about the vaccine
that people call a vaccine i call it an
injection can be mandated under 21 us
code section 360.
as an astute observer and researcher of
this entire matter of the pandemic it is
understood that the fda has not
officially approved it it is only
authorized under this emergency
authorization and i do believe that
emergency authorization as a
country
should soon
be
stopped because we are doing so well at
this point and i anticipate that that
will continue the amendment addresses
discrimination beginning on page 1 line
13 a passport infringes upon the
americans disability act and the fourth
amendment
second point medical privacy rights are
valued by most i as a registered nurse
and instructor have instilled in my
students the legal obligations and
consequences of violating the hipaa law
such privacy rights must be honored
society should not be divided into those
vaccinated and those not it's it is not
right it is divisive the amendment does
highlight healthcare healthcare workers
and their employer and the definition of
direct threat
and number three communicable disease
immunization registry
page three lines five through eight
with regard to respecting patients
patients privacy
and informed consent
the registry should be an opt-in versus
an opt-out procedure what i've seen over
my
i hate to say this 40 years as a
registered nurse is that if it's
an opt-out both in the school system and
in the medical field
it's just assumed that everybody unless
you hear otherwise wants this to be done
if you ask the medical professionals
to have it as an opt-in registry
then you are respecting the patient
you're giving them informed consent
patients expect physicians and
pharmaceutical manufacturers for example
to itemize potential risks and benefits
when proposing surgery or medications
have you listened to a tv ad marketing
the new biological drug sometimes the
side effects sound scarier than the
diagnosis
a vaccine registry with opt out
mechanism
has a high probability that the health
care provider will not be spending the
time with the patient explaining the
registry and sharing
the
and regarding sharing the immunization
records opt-out is not an acceptable
policy in my opinion with an opt-in
policy the patient is assured the
provider explains the purpose and then
the patient chooses to share the medical
record
to authorize it or not authorize it the
government is not supposed to collect
medical records of their citizens
without informed consent
when schools and colleges require
immunization records and they do for
public health reasons the current
process of retrieving the required
records from the health care provider by
the individual or the parent and
producing those school
records the immunization
uh works very well for the past 40 years
and even longer so i don't think that
that would infringe on
making sure that the schools and the
children are protected
i appreciate your time and consideration
please go one step further and support
this amendment i do believe new
hampshire citizens will appreciate your
thoughtfulness and respect for their
cherished rights i'd be happy to take
any questions thank you mr chairman
thank you very much
representative
thank you mr chair um
miss camarada you stated that you had
the antibody test is that correct yes i
yes representative
follow-up
and the
you said the cost was ten dollars was
that
the actual cost of the lab process to
analyze or was that
an insurance copay
well that's a very good question um
labcorp if you go online they
tell you that they will offer the test
and the only out-of-pocket
expense is ten dollars
so and they didn't ask well they had my
insurance information for other lab
tests so i can't be definite i can't be
certain that they didn't charge but um i
asked them if my record would be shared
with anyone and they said no so i have a
so is it likely that the rest of the
cost was covered by
either state or federal government or
something
i cannot answer that question
representative
i doubt it my sense is no because
they're not sharing that i have the test
done
well i i'm sure they can't share
personal information because of hipaa
laws but
thank you for the information
you're welcome
thank you representative cameron
i'm going to call uh julia beam
[Music]
mr minnehan
julia beam has been admitted to the
committee
yes she was
oh
thank you chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is
paula minihan senior vice president
state government relations with the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals in the
state
we will be testifying on amendment
number 1443
h to senate bill 155.
we do not have any concerns with the
underlying bill of one senate bill 155
but we do have significant concerns with
the amendment number 1443 h
and i will just go through um the items
line 20 line item number three lines 23
and 25 that language of this provision
appears to prohibit vaccines registry
which is a current law
so
we support the vaccine registry for
public health and medical treatment
purposes so we are opposed to that this
provision
item 4 lines 26 and 27
our read of this provision is that this
would effectively create and opt-in for
the vaccine registry which we are
opposed to again current law allows for
an opt-out if the patient or the parent
so chooses requiring an opt-in for the
vaccine registry is not workable and
would be extremely burdensome and
problematic it also seems to contradict
with the provisions in item three which
i commented above
or
alternatively is this intended to
require vaccine information to be
separated from the person's medical
record it's very unclear to us
item
six
um we already previously testified in
opposition to on a similar provision to
this um to a previous amendment when it
was heard in this committee um number
heard on april 27th this language is
problematic and unworkable as previously
stated um a direct threat as as is
defined is um and i won't i won't
quote it because i'm i know you're
running out of time but it is really
problematic because it requires
individual assessments of every employee
hospitals in the state of new hampshire
employ approximately forty one thousand
individuals the requirement to
individually assess each individual
employee is not feasible and equates to
an unfunded mandate
hospitals care for sick people including
those that have contracted covid19 this
must they must ensure that their staff
their patients and others that enter the
hospital are always safe the amendment
does not address public safety and
public health which must be contemplated
when considering safeguards focused on
privacy for these reasons we do not
support this amendment and we ask that
you find it in expedient to legislate
and thank you for allowing me to testify
thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
chairman
mr chairman you called on julia beam she
has been admitted to the
no to the
people who are allowed to testify so
maybe call on her
i
i called her when she was already a
but in the meantime i'm going to call on
even in music
thank you very much uh good very late
afternoon to all the members of the
executive departments and administration
committee um allow me to introduce
myself my name is ani malachi i am the
executive director of the commission for
human rights
we are a state agency and we are
responsible for the enforcement of rsa
354-a
which is where amendment 1443-h
is attempting to
attach and let me if you stand by just
one moment let me
unhook my camera and put it back in here
and
okay here we are back back with it
um so uh this amendment is uh germaine
well it's a non-german amendment
relative to rsa 354-a
which is the
new hampshire laws against
discrimination and specifically these
laws deal with
employment
housing public accommodation and k-12
education specifically dealing with the
1964 civil rights act as it relates to
immutable characteristics
of individuals i.e age sex race creed
color marital status familial status
physical or mental disability and
national origin
so
let me try to go through this as quickly
as possible
in respect to time
one of the big concerns for the
commission
is we weren't invited into the process
there's no conversation to look at what
it means for us to enforce something
like this which we are responsible for
enforcing these laws that you all would
create
um and as well as looking at the
financial piece along with this
there are several considerations here
starting on the on the very front page
there's there's deference given to the
cdc but there is no deference given to
the fda who's in charge of looking at
our drugs and determining
what has approval and what doesn't have
approval so leaving that out
could quite possibly create
issues for employees employers
businesses
across the board
also with the primary care physician
information that's stated there
specifically for the college students i
believe well i think it was for all
students
it's specific to new hampshire positions
however
that is that is arduous because there
are some people who live in the state of
new hampshire but who have doctors
potentially in vermont or massachusetts
so now you're forcing them to find a
doctor here to have this
information
dispersed as necessary
and before i go any further one of the
biggest hiccups with this that i see
is that rsa354-a
if you read it it already provides for
medical
waivers if you want to call it that as
well as religious i should say
exemptions those are already
in practice in use and have been since
the establishment of the
of the commission we've been here since
so those things are already
allowed and people do use those and what
it calls for in a situation in a work
environment is that the individual
employee enters into the interactive
process with the employer
so if there were some uh discrimination
then they would have a way to address
that within the confines of the business
provided they have done those steps and
exhausted the process within the within
the company if they don't seek the
remedy that they need they come to us
we do not charge for our services you do
not have to have an attorney we will
listen to the the citizen take their
charge and then if it crosses the the
threshold which is prima facie then we
will docket that charge and serve that
business with the charge of
discrimination in whatever the category
that i previously mentioned that they
may have done something considered
egregious and then we start that process
sometimes a business has a legitimate
reason for not um
for not doing um something that the
employee thought that they should have
done sometimes it wasn't handled the way
that the employee wanted so they're
filing a charge of discrimination
moving on um so the language here
relative to religions and irs religious
uh excuse me irs exemptions so that's ch
that's a challenge there as well because
this language facially discriminates
against other religions that are not
that are closely held beliefs that are
not recognized by the irs so there could
be some spiritual beliefs that are
closely held
that are not
given tax-exempt status by the irs and
if for for the commission if you have a
religious belief that is closely held
and you are asking for an exemption for
whatever that that area is if it's in
employment or or education or the the
areas that we cover we have jurisdiction
over you can come to us and simply are
stating it is a closely held belief now
closely held we can have that long
conversation if it's not something that
was that you decided yesterday but
something that you have followed for a
period of time and there is latitude
that is already allowed there and this
may also violate the first amendment
when you look at it on its face
regarding religion and it is also deemed
compelled speech which violates the
first amendment as well and strict
scrutiny would apply
moving down very quickly
when you look at direct threat
specifically in our statute we talk a
little bit about direct threat and
that's dealing with a health and safe
health or safety issue and as i said
before you already as an employee or as
someone in an area of public
accommodation you already have an
opportunity to enter into that
interactive process if i'm someone that
cannot get a vaccine
or i cannot wear a mask and i want to go
into this place and if they have a
mandate i can have a conversation with
that business
to work something out amongst ourselves
and that is important because that
allows
all of these things to happen
simultaneously um another uh part of the
the issue here
is
that
the uh the antibody levels are also
a question because how do you determine
what that is how do you set the bar for
whatever that litmus test is and then if
i have a reason that i need a medical or
a religious exemption
to some degree what has happened here is
something that i hold private a medical
condition that may not jeopardize what i
do in my day job but is something that
might create an issue for me to take a
vaccine and now i have to do this to opt
out of the the new legislation
now this business has been put on notice
for a variety of medical diseases or
religious beliefs that they may not have
known nor did they need to know and that
could create an opportunity for
discrimination down the line and i'll
end it by saying this
the biggest thing that you do here
is you are making a protected class of
people that do not do not have immutable
characteristics which is part of the
discussion i had with the representative
uh relative to hb 506 that let's say for
example half of the state and i and i'm
sure you all will correct me if i'm
wrong if we have roughly one point let's
just say one million people here if you
make if you pass this piece of
legislation what you've effectively done
is created a protected class of anyone
at any point in time
any
in the future from today looking 10
years back who wants to not take a
vaccine even if a position that they
hold
requires that you have now made it
discriminatory for that place of
business to require something that is
medically necessary that is a part of
the health or safety and now that that
500 000 people could potentially come
here to file a charge so i i would like
to have us think about it in that
perspective as well it's not simply
about freedom it's not simply about
medicine but there is a large
enforcement question
and the practicality of this all as well
as first amendment rights that that have
the possibility of being trampled along
with this
this amendment so whereas uh sb 155 is
very narrowly tailored
this amendment which is 144 3h is
unfortunately very overly broadly
tailored which can create a quite a few
more unintended consequences than i
think any of us could foresee at this
time so i thank you for your patience
thank you for your indulgence i
appreciate the opportunity to speak
before this body i am very happy to take
any questions that you might have
thank you representative schultz
thank you mr chair and thank you ma'am
for your testimony i don't know if this
comes up um
with the work that you do but
if it does is there anything in the
nuremberg codes that prevent mandatory
vaccination in
private businesses in new hampshire
that would and thank you very much for
the question representative schultz um
that would be outside of my jurisdiction
so specifically what i do in rsa 354-a
is the laws against discrimination that
new hampshire has created based on the
federal statute which is the civil
rights act of 1964 is where i get my
jurisdiction where i have my enforcement
and where i have my ability to take
complaints and or pass upon complaints
and so we specifically cover employment
education k through 12 which is fairly
new as well as housing and public
accommodation so i know you were looking
for something a little more specific but
i i don't have
the jurisdiction to cover that so it
would not be wise for me to speak on
something i do not have jurisdictional
authority thank you that is helpful
thank you mr malachi that'll be it thank
you very much thank you very much thank
[Music]
hello can you hear me now i can please
okay
log me off and then log me back on
um
thank you for the opportunity to speak
um today and um i wish to speak
um to amendment 1468
h
apparently there's um a couple of
amendments here my understanding is 14
43 h is no longer being considered and
there's a new amendment to consider
um i would oppose 1443 h for the record
i appreciate all the good things that
representative roy and others are doing
trying to do with this amendment 1468 h
however there are provisions written
into the amendment that are concerning
to me
i am the new hampshire director of
advocacy with the national vaccine
information center and i work to educate
and provide resources for vaccine
questions and concerns and work to
support the human right of informed
consent
i also assist
those who have been adversely impacted
by vaccination or killed by vaccines as
happens to new hampshire children and
adults on a regular basis
unfortunately many misunderstand current
new hampshire law
vaccine requirements are currently
imposed on both public and private
schools and day cares there is not the
option for those who object to
vaccination to attend a private day care
or school the mandates still apply
businesses cannot decide for themselves
i find it disingenuous the testimony of
those who claim to be opposed to this
amendment that would restrict what
businesses can and cannot do
while at the same time supporting the
current vaccine requirements in fact
telling private businesses what they
must do
expanding exemptions will not set us
back 100 years has been testified by
beth daly i have served for five years
as public member on the board of
directors of the new hampshire vaccine
association the facts are
that 74 of the vaccines purchases
purchased by dhhs through the vaccine
association and health insurers in new
hampshire
are on a voluntary basis they are not
required vaccines this is 74 of a 30
million dollar vaccine purchase program
as reported by beth daly to our board
also at the board meetings of the new
hampshire vaccine association has been
reported that vaccines given to children
dropped by about 60 percent
over this past year but there have been
no outbreaks of childhood illnesses
that impact children those are the
current facts and evidence as reported
while there are many good things in this
amendment i do object to
provision roman numeral b
that would be putting in new hampshire
statute a pathway for employer vaccine
mandates of all vaccines even while
attempting to provide exemptions
we know that exemptions have been
removed in other states and no one's
medical freedom should be subjected to
appeal to government for exemption
it will be best to leave this provision
out of this good otherwise good
amendment
i object to the amendment to rsa 141 c
20 a that would list required vaccines
and expand that list to vaccines not
currently listed in state statute
including varicella and perhaps others
some vaccines are required by rule not
statute
and rules have expiration dates and
require rule
statutes are permanent and not subject
to regular required review that rules
are
please do not add vaccine requirements
into statute with this amendment without
at the appropriate public hearings on
each and every vaccine you desire to add
to statute
it is appropriate to strike the
commissioner's authority to determine
vaccine requirements that now dhhs
now that dhhs has entered the vaccine
business this was done through rsa 126q
that created the vaccine association
this has created a conflict for dhhs a
conflict of interest that the
legislature would be correct in removing
this would allow for the legislature the
public body to propose to properly
propose and evaluate any vaccine
requirements that may be desired free of
any financial incentive or conflicts of
interest to propose to impose such
mandates it is a job of legislators to
make laws and they should retain this
duty and not surrender surrender i
support that provision
so while there are good and needed
protections in amendment 1468h
i oppose it unless the new requirements
of vaccine mandates are removed thank
you very much for the opportunity to
speak
thank you any questions
[Music]
here speak none uh thank you very much
now white control 4
mr owens
hello am i audible
yes go ahead okay thank you
my name is freddie owens from nashua new
hampshire
thank you for listening to me today i
will be as short as possible
i'm here to provide my personal
testimony and voice my support for sbe
uh live free or die our state motto so
our license places on our driver's
license we greet people into our state
with our motto
and as a new hampshire citizen we're
given the right to make decisions that
affect our life and our livelihood we
allow citizens ability to choose where
to
wear a seatbelt or not and see bill
could save your life we allow citizens
to choose to wear helmet on a motorcycle
that could also save their life we even
allow citizens to choose whether or not
to have car insurance
i can risk my life and my financial
well-being if i choose sb 55 as amended
is exactly that we allow citizens to
choose what risks they're willing to
bear
privacy of health information at one
time was an untouchable subject that
garnered the highest protection
it has been eroded in a proceeding
eroded in the preceding months and we
should not allow it to continue
no entity should be allowed to
discriminate against anyone based on
medical information
many employers have yet to discuss their
stance on the topic but however i'd like
to bring up something that i don't think
anyone has mentioned is
osha uh occupational stealth
occupational safety and health
administration issued their guidance on
employers that require vaccinations as
of 20 april
of this year and they say that any
adverse
reactions or effects of the coveted
vaccines will be a recordable incident
if the employer requires a vaccination
and a recordable instance is the first
step in which a
workman's comp claim is started
so
i think body bodily autonomy should be
sacred and should be protected uh this
concludes my text testimony thank you
thank you mr owens
what amendments he what was his
amendment number you didn't say
mr owens what was your
number
i have it as a 104 6 8 h
iterations i have it right
your
[Music]
all right thank you mr man uh the chair
thank you chairman roy for the
opportunity to appear before you and
your committee today and thank you to
the rest of the committee members
my name is burton dibble i'm a family
physician i live in the town of rye in
new hampshire
i've practiced medicine for 44 years
and had many children and many vaccine
recipients in my practice
i have also been a member of the board
of registration and medicine and i am a
past president
of the new hampshire medical society
and i testify here today on behalf of
myself and on behalf of the medical
society
you have heard a broad
agreement from your new hampshire
physicians
10 or 11 of them now
that to impose limitations on
vaccination is a very bad public health
idea
and
i'm
personally opposed to that as well
i think we
have lost a little bit of
the broader perspective in the
discussion of the details here
i would like to point out the example of
smallpox
a scourge which is no longer with us
and
the
removal of that disease from the world
was an accomplishment of vaccine
and i can remember in my junior high
school years
in the 1950s
the terror in my parents voices in the
springtime when the fear of polio was
the discussion around living room coffee
tables
and
families flocking to the town hall
lining up children to get vaccines
and
now i can testify as a person involved
with rotary international
that polio has nearly been wiped out of
the world
it exists only in
two nations any longer
and there's reasonable hope
that that problem will be put to bed
so it is a bit of a mystery to me
personally
why we're throwing barriers up to
immunization
when it has such a terrific proven track
record
and particularly to the covid vaccine
when we have seen
death rates
hospitalization rates and severity of
disease
involvement
plummet in places where vaccine is well
distributed
i speak specifically
for the medical society as well
to the
vaccine registry matter
we've heard discussion
uh testimony
that
the vaccine registry is a federal
requirement for us to be able to carry
on our covet vaccine program
i think as another public health matter
we have had terrible behavioral health
issues
with suicide
to some degree more importantly to
greater involvement
with the opioid epidemic
and
every
detail that i can think of supports the
notion of more adequate vaccination
including childhood vaccines not less
and then i would like to speak
specifically to
the
opt-out versus opt-in
discussion
and
it's clear even though there's been
conflicting testimony
that
opt in
is another barrier to vaccination
you've heard testimony from the hospital
association
and i'd like to present that testimony
on behalf of myself
and the new hampshire medical society
and i would be happy to speak any
questions that you might have
thank you
if you have uh written testimony please
yes i wanted to thank dr dibble for
testifying today he is a constituent of
mine and i appreciate hello i appreciate
your um
your um the time that you're dedicated
to come and speak less and thank you
very much for your expertise in this
matter
thank you representative grota
mr mcleod you can unmute yourself
uh
mr chair and members of committee my
name is thomas cloud from mount vernon
new hampshire i am the chair of the
liberty defense fund in new hampshire
testifying today as a private citizen
i want to i'll be brief uh i want to
point out a few points uh contrary to dr
smith's testimony that reported injuries
and bears are misrepresented or unproven
a cdc-funded study that concluded in
found that fewer than one percent of
actual vaccine injuries form the basis
of of report and bears
therefore up to 99
of actual injuries go unimported
unreported
the name of the study was the electronic
support for public
health vaccine adverse event reporting
system aka the harvard pilgrim vera
study
um mr chair the supreme court has not
ruled on
adult vaccine mandates since the 1905
decision in jacobson versus
massachusetts
a time well before the development of
modern medical essex
even then what the court upheld was a
five dollar fine
against a preacher who had religious and
medical objections to the smallpox
vaccination
this was not a case of a possible
devastating loss of career or livelihood
there is significant doubt at this time
where the court would uphold an employer
vaccine mandate against a sincere
religious objection
in contrast to the testimony of the
representative of the new hampshire
commission for human rights
for many with long-standing religious
objections
the vaccine-free state of their physical
bodies is a permanent attribute
after all what we are talking about
today is discrimination based on the
physical attribute that is whether their
immune systems are modified by a vaccine
or not
i find it interesting that certain
witnesses have questioned the regulation
of private businesses
that practice discrimination and hiring
and employment
mr chairman the civil rights act of 1964
was a landmark legislation that held
private employers and public
accommodations to a standard of human
rights that prohibited them from taking
certain actions that were discriminatory
in nature
if we reject this amendment based on the
theory that we cannot regulate
discrimination in private businesses are
we calling into questioning the entire
premise of the civil rights movement in
this country i hope not and that will
conclude my testimony thank you for
staying uh this late hour on this issue
thank you
thank you for your time
my name is curtis barry uh here uh this
afternoon on behalf of the new hampshire
retail association
uh and i'll be speaking specifically
about
uh
section roman seven a that's on page two
line nine
the new hampshire retail association
represents
retailers of all sizes large and small
but over 90 percent of the membership is
new hampshire-based businesses
the section that i'm speaking to
has two prohibitions in it
the first prohibition would prevent an
employer from simply asking about the
vaccine status
and the second would include a
prohibition about making an employment
decision and that language many of our
members pointed out is not specific on
what an employment decision is and i'll
get into that in a little bit
but the opposition
really begins with the question for the
association members and that is whether
or not business owners may control their
workplace
in fact
among the responses we got from members
when asking about this particular
amendment it was very frequent for
members to use the term government
overreach
now employers are responsible for the
safety
of both employees and customers that's a
reality
they have to make decisions on a daily
basis on a regular basis about safety
practices all the time
and that may include knowing which
employees are vaccinated for several
reasons
for example the amendment does not take
into account a business owner wishing to
protect at-risk employees for example
employees who cannot take a vaccine due
to analogy
it also does not take into account
retailers whose employees must enter
other locations to deliver uh items such
as appliances or furniture
large quantities of of goods
um in a location where there might be a
person at risk
whether it's the population is at risk
or a single person
without the ability to know who who is
and who isn't vaccinated a retailer
cannot make decisions about personnel
and scheduling
when they're aware of those
circumstances so
lastly i would point out that if the
business owner cannot ask a person about
vaccination status then perhaps in some
circumstance they can't loosen
restrictions that they would impose in
the business on employees wearing masks
or customers distancing
as soon as they can if they knew uh
which employees were vaccinated
i'm happy to answer your questions mr
chair
uh i just a
tough question answer i'm not sure
you're going to be able to answer
how do you
uh prevent businesses from
discriminating
against people based on their medical
records
well representative lekkas i think that
question is a little bit broader than
the the vaccine status contemplated in
in the amendment
um medical records are one thing this
amendment strictly deals with vaccine
status although it's all vaccine status
and not not just covet
so you're right i'm not sure i can
answer that question fully
thank you
thank you mr chairman
uh good afternoon mr berry
uh
good to see you i appreciate your
testimony because it certainly widens
the scope of uh
incidents that are instances that i was
concerned about and what we've heard
about up to this point
um
but one of the one of the things that i
don't know if you've been on the hearing
the entire time but one of the
things one of the things that good
because i i raised a point that i'd like
to have you comment on and that is that
um
we've gotten a lot of emails on this
committee
mostly in support of the amendment uh
but because they have a common theme i
think that they are very possibly
generated or
motivated driven by a common source
and one of the things that that that
that they protest against is the idea of
curating a two-tiered society where you
got the vaccinated and the unvaccinated
and they're not being treated equally um
that certainly is a troubling situation
uh but to the degree that that
that we have businesses in the initial
amendment neither one of them have been
adopted
as you know
uh
the uh the initial
amendment
talked
about any business which did business
would have to abide by they were to be
adopted right enacted
now as i understand that the new um
amendment is going to make all
businesses uh subject to it
uh
does that strike you
that's that clearly would have been a
two-tiered society right some businesses
are prohibited under the statute
some would have been um and would have
been free to do whatever they wanted to
um in that regard
i think the new amendment is going to
spread it statewide
uh is that workable in your judgment
gets rid of the two-tiered situation to
some degree
but but it but it imposes
now on every business in the state is is
that workable in your judgment
i'm not sure if if i can answer that
question that you know i think a legal
expert would have to weigh in on whether
it's workable or not um you may have
noticed representative schmidt the
retail association did not
i did not present verbal testimony on
that that previous hearing on the on the
previous amendment um
and i should mention by the way that i
think ms malachi touched on the
discrimination portion of the bill
because it seemed to come in two
sections which is why i didn't speak to
it um
but you know relative to a two-tiered
system i think
you know no matter what employment
decisions people are making uh you know
employers make a lot of decisions that
they feel are good for their business
and good for their customer base with
the exception of those areas that are
protected within the
human rights statute
so i'm not sure if this is creating a
two-tiered system i think the bottom
line for our members is they want to be
able to control
their own work space
especially with regard to health
right
thank you and good to see you all as
well
nice to see you too
all right thank you mr barry
my pleasure
um
i'm going to now call on
okay thank you
hello everyone my my name is leslie
nuchow
i'm a musician and a registered nurse
and i wish you could see
the image that i have in front of me
right now
it is of a native american lakota man
in shackles
with a ball and chain
he was being punished because he had his
own personal medical beliefs
he was made a second-class citizen
because of his own personal medical
beliefs
my family and i fled to new hampshire
seeking refuge for our own personal
medical beliefs
new hampshire stands as not only a
symbol of freedom
but a tangible haven for people like us
to institute a vaccine passport would
make second-class citizens of people
like me and my family
as we know vaccines are not risk-free
so to mandate a medical procedure
like the vaccine would remove my right
to bodily autonomy
and this is a human right
this is why i support sb-155's amendment
1468-h banning vaccine passports
and protecting our individual rights as
sovereign human beings to make our own
personal medical decisions please do not
make us out of second-class citizens
please do not punish us with a ball and
at this point i'm going to call mr gary
abbott
great thank you very much chairman uh
for the record my name's gary abbott i'm
the executive vice president of the
associated general contractors of new
hampshire
this being a late bill i have not
completely vetted this with all the
association members
but i want to raise something a concern
it really is in regard to the same thing
curtis berry kind of talked about
which is uh
this part seven of the bill a of the
bill regarding um
you know the assessment of direct threat
i represent commercial and industrial
contractors
some of those building contractors work
directly for health care nursing homes
those kind of things we're anticipating
because of the coronavirus that's those
institutions that have put in place that
everyone needs to be vaccinated that
works there
when we come in to do a project they may
through our contract put that we have to
be vaccinated as well
so i'm raising the concern here because
it's not really clear reading the
language of the bill
if i'm not allowed because i don't do
those projects every day
and i'm and i might not meet the
complete definition here there'll be a
question there'll definitely be a legal
question that comes up
because my business does try to work on
one of those projects if i'm not able to
ask of whether an employee has been
vaccinated
that could create some real difficulties
in the future
so i just wanted to bring that up to the
committee as a concern
it's really a contractual concern of us
going to work for another party
that is
and i in my definition might be
classified under this direct threat
language
but it's just not clear
when i'm hiring people throughout the
year that i can ask that question
because those people that are not
vaccinated
through the contract probably will not
be allowed to work on that project but
it looks like there's an awful lot of
questions that my members will have for
me and i just wanted to raise that with
the committee i know my testimony is
much different than what you've heard
before
but it's more of the legal of how this
is going to work when some businesses
meet that
definition of direct threat
where the people i represent end up
having to go to those places that are
into that condition with that i would
end my testimony i'm not really
into the other
uh effective of the vaccine and all of
those other issues that you've heard
today but really just wanted to make
sure that the committee was aware that
we we do have some concerns of how that
would work for businesses that fluctuate
between types
thank you
thank you for bringing that to the
committee's attention
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
see any questions so thank you
the least likely lobbyist i would have
expected to see today gary well you know
i will tell you i i listened to the
early testimony
and then i was able to come back wasn't
able to stay with you but i just wanted
to raise that because this is similar to
some other issues that we've run into
statutes before
but
i just wanted to make sure the committee
was aware
thank you for that
good afternoon um uh chairman roy and
members of
the committee thank you very much for
the opportunity to testify
for the record my name is courtney
tanner i'm the director of government
relations at dartmouth-hitchcock
denver's hitchcock has serious concerns
about this amendment and i'll uh uh
limit my testimony to two specific um
provisions in this uh bill i know you've
heard a lot of testimony today so my
testimony is um the first point is going
to sound a lot like mr berries and mr
abbotts
our mission and our primary
responsibility is to provide quality
care and a safe environment and
hospitals and health facilities employ a
variety of
in a variety of strategies to ensure a
safe environment and one of the elements
of that of that strategy is a healthy
workforce
we have significant concerns about the
exemption for the medical facilities
contemplated in this amendment
specifically that direct threat language
implementing this
exemption would be more than an
administrative burden we actually
believe would be near impossible
dartmouth hitchcock health employs over
13 000 employees it's our responsibility
to ensure that all of our employees are
healthy and prepared to serve our
patients across the state
i want to highlight for you that we do
for our current annual influenza program
right now one is a religious exemption
one's a medical exemption both of those
exemptions are working and they do work
for our employees that look for those
exemptions
as a committee you work on examining
laws that govern various professional
boards you hear testimony and you learn
about
the
significant workforce challenges that we
face here in new hampshire we are
navigating serious workforce challenges
and we don't have the ability to simply
move around our staff if they refuse
vaccination
passage of this amendment would
significantly impact our ability to
staff our hospitals and therefore we
believe it would impact patient care and
access to care
uh second the second reason why we're
concerned about this amendment is as
representative marsh testified the house
health and human services committee
already heard a bill that contemplated
an opt-out process for our state vaccine
registry that was house bill 221.
in that hearing i testified in
opposition of the bill and i raised up
dr
keith loud
written testimony that he submitted
dr loud is the chief
physician at the state's only children's
hospital chad at dartmouth-hitchcock and
of course i didn't read dr lad's
testimony but i did highlight a couple
of key points
cloven 19 has served as a reminder that
the value of immunizations we know that
immunizations work
vaccine registries are a tool in our
toolbox to increase and sustain
sufficient vaccine rates and a
systematic universal registry allows
citizens to seek and obtain
vaccines in a safe and convenient way
and keeps our providers informed
we believe that an opt-out an opt-in
process
would be a back a step backwards for new
hampshire an opt-in registry would
hinder new hampshire's work to improve
the health and safety of our children
and our communities
we strongly urge the committee to vote
down this amendment and i'm willing to
any questions
uh if i could do you have a a copy of
the testimony you referred to regarding
the opt-in opt-out from the previous
committee
and if you could could you email it to
me please i'm happy to do that it's not
it's a
public document and i'm happy to send
that to you
thank you i appreciate it
[Music]
thank you chairman roy members of the
committee for the record my name is dave
duvet i'm a senior vice president with
the business and industry association we
serve as new hampshire statewide chamber
of commerce we have over 400 member
companies employing over 90 000 people
in the state i am here this afternoon
testifying in opposition
to the non-germain amendment 1443 h we
have no position on the underlying bill
senate bill 155. um i think at this
point i will be very brief you have
heard from a number of different uh
individuals representing employers
curtis berry with the retailers gary
abbott representing um uh the
construction industry uh paula minahan
representing hospitals in our membership
we have
manufacturing
hospitals um financial services
organizations
uh
business services
groups attorneys
cpas and so on and we find this bill to
be completely problematic
i am asking the committee to please
resist the temptation
to have government dictate to business
what is in
uh best left to an employer's uh
decision making in conjunction within
his employees we've already heard that
businesses are being held to an
extraordinarily high standard for health
and safety please allow them
to
develop the
best
rules for their individual workplaces
and don't try and force something on
them in terms of
discussions earlier about
those who may have allergies or other
medical issues why they shouldn't be
vaccinated or those who have
closely held religious beliefs we
understand that
that that is um
that is common in the workplace
and in those situations employers will
uh meet individually and make reasonable
comment accommodations it happens every
day but this amendment doesn't even
allow that conversation to begin to take
place so i urge you to reject this
amendment i'd be happy to answer any
questions and thank you again for the
opportunity to testify
representative
good afternoon mr juve and thank you for
justifying
can you um
um
be specific a little bit about the kinds
of businesses you've heard from who
yeah well it really uh thank you for the
question representative grota it really
is across the board but i would like to
uh remind members of the committee
although they try and carve out an
exemption for
health care workers i'm assuming they're
referring to hospitals there's all kinds
of other businesses that
that
have vulnerable um
uh individuals that that are either a
part of the business or or customers of
the business like day care centers or
um
assisted living facilities even places
like airports when you think of the
number of people going in and out of an
airport each day there's extraordinary
risk associated uh
by creating a situation where an
employee an employer can't even have a
discussion with their employee about
whether they're vaccinated and if they
aren't would they be open to some other
type of reasonable accommodation um
you know i
i i
this is not a good amendment and the
issues that other uh individuals
representing employers have raised
is a good reason why
it's in general not a good idea for
government to be telling employers how
to run their businesses they
there's just too many
opportunities for unintended
consequences
you know
mr giuve it's unfortunate for you that
i've that you're
i'm going to ask you this question i've
heard all afternoon i guess i
volunteered to sit here for four hours
so i can't blame anybody but me
yeah as did i
well okay but
we well you probably got paid more than
i did anyway
i i'm being cranky i don't really want
to be
look
this business about business government
not telling business what to do this is
just really
hard to sit through all afternoon
i can't pay my employees
i have to pay time and a half after 40
hours
there's nothing immoral about straight
time but the government has stepped in
i'm looking at two exit signs up there
government told me to put up those exit
signs this is my workplace i had
somebody had to put those up
so i don't know what you can say to it
but it's not i it's a hard argument for
me to accept that the government isn't
telling us what to do in our workplaces
so if you want to comment that's fine
i'm maybe just being pranked
no thank you representative and i
appreciate you warning me about your
crankiness in advance so um i would like
to respond and i'm not suggesting that
government has never
suggested to businesses um how those
businesses should be run we could
probably point to a thousand different
regulations
and every single time legislators such
as yourself have to
make the decision is this in the best
interest of the business and the
employee or is it not
i would suggest that this
amendment
is clearly not in the best interest of
i was kind of hoping you wouldn't be
reasonable
mr sure yes just maybe a related
question to you and that is um
how long are we planning on being here
today or do you expect to be here today
um very shortly
um
so that was our last witness
and as
as chair and as
sponsor of the amendment i think i've
done a
yeoman's job of holding my tongue
throughout the entire hearing
and now i'm going to allow myself a
and
then we will be done
the reason that i introduced this
amendment
was at the behest of
constituents
and in my reading of the constitution
i can't find the word business anywhere
um but i find i find people individuals
everywhere
the thought that because it's more
convenient or better for business
we can force individual citizens
to take a medication a
vaccination an experiment we don't even
know what it is at this point
because some data looks good
it's just it's it's in my mind
reprehensible
to the constitution it just does not
drive you cannot make excuses
to take people's bodily autonomy away
from them
because it's for the common good
um that's not the constitution doesn't
contemplate the common good that
contemplates uh individual liberty
and i can't think of anything more
intrusive than to tell someone what
they're going to do with their body
and i you know i i
i'm pro-life
and um i held through that and i voted
against the death penalty and i hope
that when this time comes that people
that
often see my body my choice um apply
that to this as well it's an
individual's choice what they're going
that's why i introduced this amendment
and i will not be taking any questions
so please have a good day
and i'll see you all next week
um mr chair i did notice
sorry but i did notice that
representative horrigan
who didn't get to complete what he
wanted to say is has had his hand up
yes uh he talked for about eight minutes
and i figured that was quite enough
but i'm happy it's fair enough
[Music]